I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. We are here with Nepotism. And a big ole lift up to start this episode. And we have all the details about it. Welcome to Office Ladies.
我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。我们带着《裙带关系》来了。本集一开始就有一个大大的助推。我们掌握了关于它的所有细节。欢迎来到《办公室女士》。
Welcome to Office Ladies. It is season seven, episode one, written by Daniel Chun, directed by Jeffrey Blitz. We've got some great fast facts today. We really do. And we did a real two-hander on the fast facts today. We did. We did. We did.
欢迎来到《办公室女士》。这是第七季第一集，由丹尼尔·陈编剧，杰弗里·布利茨执导。今天我们有一些很棒的快讯。确实如此。而且我们今天在快讯环节做了个双人搭档。确实是的。确实。确实。
And I loved it. I hope we'll always do it this way. I see what you're doing. Season seven, you're like, Ange, this is it. Fast facts have become a two-hander. Here is your summary. Summer is over. Once again, the cameras did not follow us over the summer.
我很喜欢。我希望我们以后一直这样。我看出你在搞什么鬼了。第七季，你就像是，安吉，就是这样。快讯变成双人档了。这是你的总结。夏天结束了。摄像机再一次没有在夏天跟踪拍摄我们。
For a reason, we don't know. Yeah, we don't know. They take the summer off. Dwight now owns Scranton Business Park. He did it. Michael has brought in a new assistant for the office, Luke, but nobody likes him. He's completely incompetent. Michael will not fire him because we find out that Luke is his nephew.
原因不明。对，我们不知道。他们放暑假了。德怀特现在拥有了斯克兰顿商业园。他做到了。迈克尔为办公室新招了一个助理卢克，但没人喜欢他。他完全不称职。迈克尔不肯解雇他，因为我们发现卢克是他的外甥。
Yeah. Gabe and Aaron are dating. Yeah, that happened over the summer when the cameras were off. Yeah, apparently Gabe, you know, checked in with Andy first about it and he said it was fine. Yeah, Andy is pretending like he's fine. And finally in this episode, Pam is going to play a trick on Dwight because she messed up this sort of long con prank that Jim was working on with Dwight's keys,
盖布和艾琳在约会。是的，那是夏天摄像机不在的时候发生的。对，显然盖布，你知道的，先跟安迪沟通过，安迪说没问题。对，安迪假装自己没事。最后在本集里，帕姆要对德怀特恶作剧，因为她搞砸了吉姆一直在用德怀特钥匙进行的那个长期恶作剧，
and she wants to try to make it up to him. So that's what's happening this episode. SONIA DARA-WIJEEVSKI Should we get into fast facts? KATE BOWEN Yes, see how excited you are for that because you are part of the fast facts. SONIA DARA-WIJEEVSKI That's not why I'm excited. KATE BOWEN Look at your enthusiasm, lady. SONIA DARA-WIJEEVSKI That's not why I'm excited. KATE BOWEN You could have this every week. SONIA DARA-WIJEEVSKI Stop.
她想弥补他。这就是这一集发生的事情。索尼娅·达拉-维杰夫斯基 我们该切入快讯了吗？凯特·鲍恩 对，看你多兴奋，因为你也是快讯的一部分。索尼娅·达拉-维杰夫斯基 我兴奋不是因为这个。凯特·鲍恩 瞧你这热情劲儿，女士。索尼娅·达拉-维杰夫斯基 我兴奋不是因为这个。凯特·鲍恩 你每周都能有这待遇。索尼娅·达拉-维杰夫斯基 别介。
KATE BOWEN Fast fact number one. This was our season premiere and also Steve Carell's last season. Like we said last week, before season six ended, the cast and crew knew that this would be his last season, but the news was officially announced publicly over the summer break. And there were a lot of opinions about it. Oh, yeah. Mostly people were saying that the office would be dead without Steve. This news also put a lot of focus on our season premiere episode. In fact, it was seen by 8.4 million viewers, which was a big bump from our season six finale
凯特·鲍恩 快讯第一条。这是我们的季首播集，也是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的最后一个季度。就像我们上周说的，在第六季结束前，演员和剧组就知道这将是他的最后一年，但这个消息是在暑假期间才正式向公众宣布的。对此有很多不同的看法。哦，是的。大家大多都在说，没有了史蒂夫，《办公室》就完蛋了。这个消息也让我们的季首播集备受关注。事实上，它吸引了840万观众收看，比我们第六季大结局的
of 6.6 million. So almost two more million people tuned in. Nicole Sarris That's a lot. I know. The writers spent a lot of time over the summer talking about how to craft Steve's last season. Their big question was, why does Michael leave Dunder Mifflin? Yeah, because he loves Dunder Mifflin. It's his family. Exactly. Well, Paul Lieberstein said one thing they discussed was Michael getting fired at the end. And we had set this up a little bit with the problems with Sabre and the printers. He'd become kind of like the spokesperson. So there was discussion like maybe that was
660万观众有了大幅增长。所以差不多又多了两百万观众收看。妮可·萨里斯 这真是个大数字。我知道。编剧们在夏天花了大量时间讨论如何构思史蒂夫的最后一季。他们面临的重大问题是：迈克尔为什么要离开邓德·米弗林？对，因为他爱邓德·米弗林。那是他的家。没错。好吧，保罗·利伯斯坦说他们讨论过的一个方案是迈克尔在最后被解雇。我们之前通过萨布丽和打印机的问题为这铺垫过一点。他变得有点像代言人。所以大家讨论过也许这些
all going to cave in and he'd have to leave. Yeah, he'd be the fall guy for Sabre. Yes. But ultimately they thought that was like not doing right by Michael Scott. They decided that they really wanted him to grow. They wanted him to find love. They wanted him to have a really positive and iconic goodbye. So I listened to the DVD commentary for this episode. By the way, you guys, I have a whole story about what it took for me just to watch a DVD. It was a journey. Amazing. Because you were in Texas visiting your family.
全都会崩溃，然后他不得不离开。对，他会成为萨布丽的替罪羊。是的。但最终他们认为那样对不起迈克尔·斯科特。他们决定真的想让他成长。他们想让他找到真爱。他们想给他一个非常积极且标志性的告别。所以我听了这一集的DVD评论音轨。顺便说一句，伙计们，我有一个完整的故事，讲我为了看一张DVD费了多大劲。那真是一段旅程。太棒了。因为你在德州探亲。
Yeah. In a very small town. Anyway, I will save that because we have so much to cover, but I have to share later. Anyway, so I finally was able to watch this DVD. It featured Craig Robinson, Creed Bratton, writers Danny Chen, BJ Novak, and Paul Lieberstein. Danny, BJ, and Paul talked about this being Michael's last season, and how they wanted to approach storylines for him.
对。在一个非常小的镇上。不管怎样，我先不说了，因为我们要讲的内容太多了，但我待会儿必须分享。总之，我终于能看这张DVD了。里面有克雷格·罗宾逊、克里德·布拉顿、编剧丹尼·陈、B·J·诺瓦克和保罗·利伯斯坦。丹尼、B·J和保罗谈到这是迈克尔的最后一季，以及他们想如何为他构思剧情线。
And I found this conversation so interesting. Jenna, we love the whole writer's process. We love it. And they shared that this episode kicked off a change in Michael. Because his coworkers were his family, and him bringing his actual nephew, his actual family into the office, he has to try to figure out how to separate work from family. Mm.
我觉得这段对话太有趣了。詹娜，我们爱极了整个编剧流程。我们太爱了。他们分享说这一集拉开了迈克尔转变的序幕。因为他的同事就是他的家人，而他把真正的外甥、真正的家人带进办公室，他必须开始琢磨如何将工作与家庭分开。嗯。
And they also said that they just wanted to show Michael's growth as a person. Here, they say it better than I do. Let's listen. You know, telling Michael that's mixing business and family, these are his two favorite things. Right. So he, of all people, would not see the problem here. Just couldn't understand. And this was kind of, this came about from us talking about Steve's last season and what are the stories that are kind of... Yeah, the whole season is sort of about that.
他们还说，他们只是想展现迈克尔作为个人的成长。在这里，他们比我表达得更好。我们来听听。你知道，告诉迈克尔那是将公事和家事混为一谈，这可是他最喜欢的两件事。没错。所以他绝对是所有人中最看不出问题的人。就是无法理解。这有点像是我们在讨论史蒂夫的最后一季以及什么样的故事才算……对，整季基本上就是围绕这个展开。
Point essential Michael's stories that we just never told. And we were able to kind of have him grow in a way that he wasn't... Yeah, the whole season we would approach Michael finally letting Michael have grown a bit by the end of an episode, which we generally never did. Setting him off in style. Yeah, because we, you know... We wanted him to be like a more of a whole person by the time he left. Yeah, we knew more or less how he was going to leave. be like a more of a whole person by the time he left. Yeah, we knew more or less how he was going to leave.
核心要点是那些我们从未讲述过的迈克尔的故事。我们得以让他以一种他以前没有的方式成长……对，整个季度我们都会这样处理：最后让迈克尔在每集结束时稍微成长一点，这通常是我们从不做的。让他拉风地离开。对，因为我们，你知道……我们希望他在离开时能更像一个完整的人。对，我们多多少少知道他会怎么离开。更像一个完整的人。对，我们多多少少知道他会怎么离开。
Yeah, often up till this season, Michael would just find a new level of denial to end it. Right, right. And that would be funny. But we could start firing off our Michael self-awareness gun because we knew we only had a few bullets anyway. Yeah, I remember that. That there was this just overall idea of Michael growing into a man that could leave and marry Holly because they knew that was the end. That was the goal.
对，在这季之前，迈克尔通常都是靠进入新一层的否认来结束。没错，没错。那会很好笑。但我们可以开始发射我们的迈克尔自我觉醒之枪，反正我们知道子弹不多了。对，我记得那个。就是有一种整体的观念，让迈克尔成长为一个能够离开并娶霍莉的男人，因为他们知道那是结局。那是目标。
Yes, but we only had one season to get them there now. Right, and it is interesting now as we rewatch this whole season seven, you are going to see Michael becoming more self-aware, more aware of his actions and how they affect other people. Really cool. All right. Fast fact number two, we have a couple of casting announcements. First up, Zach Woods, who plays Gabe, was made a series regular for season seven. We were so happy to have him.
是的，但我们现在只有一个季度的时间让他们达成目标。没错，现在当我们重温整个第七季时会很有趣，你会看到迈克尔变得越来越有自我意识，更能意识到自己的行为以及它们如何影响其他人。真的很酷。好了。快讯第二条，我们有几条选角公告。首先，饰演盖布的扎克·伍兹成为了第七季的常规演员。我们很高兴有他加入。
And, speaking of Michael Scott's nephew, Luke, Luke was played by Evan Peters. And boy, did we get a fan mail flurry. I bet we did. I mean, Evan's career has just skyrocketed. Oh yeah. Fan question from Olivia R. in St. Louis, Missouri. Hi ladies! Did you know that Evan Peters grew up in St. Louis? Jenna, he grew up in the suburb of Baldwin. Do you know it? I just love all of the St. Louis connections on the office because I am from there myself. Well, Olivia, yes I know Baldwin
说到迈克尔·斯科特的侄子卢克，卢克由埃文·彼得斯饰演。天哪，我们收到了雪片般的粉丝来信。我敢说确实如此。我是说，埃文的职业生涯简直是一飞冲天。哦，是的。来自密苏里州圣路易斯的奥利维亚·R的粉丝提问。嗨，女士们！你们知道埃文·彼得斯是在圣路易斯长大的吗？詹娜，他在鲍德温郊区长大。你知道吗？我太喜欢《办公室》里所有圣路易斯的联系了，因为我自己就来自那里。嗯，奥利维亚，我当然知道鲍德温，
because I grew up in Baldwin. Wait, you and Evan grew up in the same part of town? Yes, yes. Oh my gosh. In Baldwin, Missouri, a suburb of St. Louis. Not at the same time. I am significantly older than Evan. I wasn't going to say anything.
因为我就是在鲍德温长大的。等等，你和埃文在镇上的同一个地方长大？对，对。噢天哪。在密苏里州的鲍德温，圣路易斯的一个郊区。不是同一时间。我比埃文大得多。我本来不想说的。
Possible I could be his mother. But yes, Baldwin, Missouri, home of Queenie Park. I'm sure he must have ice skated at Queenie Park, same as me. Great part of town. How about that? I know. Another fan question from Sierra P in Gresham, Oregon. I have to share a monk connection. Monk was randomly on TV the other day and Evan Peters was on. No way. It was season seven, episode two, Mr. Monk and the Genius.
我当他妈都有可能。不过是的，密苏里州鲍德温，奎尼公园的所在地。我敢肯定他一定在奎尼公园滑过冰，跟我一样。镇上很棒的地方。怎么样？我知道。来自俄勒冈州格雷厄姆的塞拉·P的另一个粉丝提问。我必须分享一个《神探阿蒙》的联系。《神探阿蒙》前几天随机在电视上播出，埃文·彼得斯就在里面。不可能。那是第七季第二集，《阿蒙先生与天才》。
No way. Lady gets on. I have a connection to Evan. Yeah, I've got a St. Louis connection. You've got a monk connection. Okay, okay. Also Lady, he was on House. No way. So we've got another guest star in the House. Oh, you love that pun.
不可能。女士上场了。我跟埃文有联系。对，我有圣路易斯联系。你有个《神探阿蒙》联系。好吧，好吧。还有女士，他演过《豪斯医生》。不可能。所以我们在《豪斯医生》里又有一个客串明星。哦，你太喜欢这个双关语了。
It's like your favorite pun. It's going to be my new thing. Every guest star, I'm going to see if they were on House. Oh lordy. Get ready for it, everyone. You've just got three seasons of me doing that. You're probably happy I didn't think of it sooner. And I'm sad. I'll tell you a little bit about Evan, guys.
这就像你最喜欢的双关语。这要成为我的新招牌了。每个客串明星，我都要看看他们是不是演过《豪斯医生》。哦天哪。大家准备好吧。你们接下来得看我玩三季这个。你们大概庆幸我没早点想到这个吧。而我很伤心。我跟你们讲讲埃文的事，伙计们。
He moved to Los Angeles when he was 15 years old with his mom to pursue his acting career. He landed roles in film and TV productions such as Parenthood, One Tree Hill, The Mentalist, House, Monk. He's probably best known for his work in nine seasons of the American Horror Story anthology and the X-Men film series. Quicksilver! He's Quicksilver! I know.
他15岁时和妈妈一起搬到洛杉矶去追求演艺事业。他获得了许多电影和电视剧的演出机会，比如《为人父母》、《篮球兄弟》、《超感神探》、《豪斯医生》、《神探阿蒙》。他最著名的作品可能是在《美国恐怖故事》选集九季中的表演以及《X战警》系列电影。快银！他是快银！我知道。
Evan also recently won a Primetime Emmy Award for his work in Mare of Easttown. He was so good in that. I was very, I don't want to give a spoiler, but I was very upset. I know. I know. It wrecked me. You won't say what happened. We won't say. I know. I know. It wrecked me. We won't say what happened. We won't say.
埃文最近还凭借在《东城梦魇》中的表演赢得了黄金时段艾美奖。他在那里面演得太棒了。我非常……我不想剧透，但我非常难过。我知道。我知道。我被打击到了。你不会说发生了什么吧。我们不会说。我知道。我知道。我被打击到了。我们不会说发生了什么吧。我们不会说。
Oh, he was so good in it. What David Denman? Crossover connection with David Denman. There's another crossover connection. Okay. The office was not his first time working with Steve Carell. They were also in a film together called Sleepover from 2004. I saw that.
哦，他在里面太棒了。大卫·丹曼呢？与大卫·丹曼的跨界联系。还有另一个跨界联系。好吧。《办公室》并不是他第一次和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作。他们还一起演过一部2004年的电影叫《睡前小故事》。我看过那个。
Is Steve like a mall cop or something? Yeah, he's like a comedic security guard. Yes. And it's basically about these four girls who are having a sleepover and then they go on this wild night out scavenger hunt. And then Evan is part of a group of guys. It's a very comedic role. Like he's very goofy in it.
史蒂夫演的是不是类似商场保安什么的？对，他就像个搞笑的保安。是的。故事基本上是四个女孩开睡梦派对，然后去进行一场疯狂的夜间寻宝游戏。然后埃文是其中一群男孩里的一个。这是一个非常搞笑的角色。他在里面非常滑稽。
He's one of the high school kids. He has an amazing dance number. I saw that so long ago. I don't think he and Steve had any scenes together in that though. But there is also going to be, after he did his role in The Office, a future crossover connection, which is that he was in the movie Kick Ass with Clark Duke. Evan, you have so many office crossovers. I know.
他是高中生之一。他有一段精彩绝伦的舞蹈。我好久以前看过了。不过我觉得他在里面和史蒂夫没有什么对手戏。但在他演完《办公室》之后，也会有一个未来的跨界联系，那就是他和克拉克·杜克一起演了电影《海扁王》。埃文，你客串过《办公室》的人实在太多了。我知道。
You can also come hang out with us anytime and you can talk all about it. Yeah, come on over. Come on over. We'll give you some shortbread cookies and Josh will bake something. Yeah. And oh, I'll make you a gooey butter cake. There you go. To remind you of home. St. Yeah. And oh, I'll make you a gooey butter cake. There you go. To remind you of home. St. Louis. All right, lady. Do you want a sip of tea or something? Because I will. I have made myself a wonderful iced tea because Lip Dub is about to happen.
你也可以随时来跟我们闲逛，你可以畅谈这一切。对，过来吧。过来吧。我们会请你吃黄油酥饼，乔什会烤点东西。对。哦，我会给你做一个黏黏黄油蛋糕。给你。让你想起家乡。圣……对。哦，我会给你做一个黏黏黄油蛋糕。给你。让你想起家乡。圣路易斯。好吧，女士。你想喝口茶什么的吗？因为我要喝。我给自己泡了一杯棒极了的冰茶，因为快闪就要上演了。
That's right. Our fast fact three is going to be breaking down that famous Lip Dub cold open. We got so many questions about this lip dub. I think we should just go through them one by one. We reached out to a lot of folks to get these answers for you. We did. We were busy. It was fun. It was really fun. I was also just so impressed with how quickly people got back to us. So thank you to everyone we reached out to. Jenna, list them off. We reached out to Randy Cordray, of course, our cinematographer, Matt Sohn, our editor, Dave Rogers,
没错。我们的快讯第三条将剖析那个著名的快闪开场。我们收到了关于这个快闪的大量提问。我觉得我们应该逐一解答。我们联系了很多人来为你们寻找这些答案。我们确实这么做了。我们很忙。这很有趣。真的非常有趣。我也对大家回复我们的速度之快印象深刻。所以感谢我们联系过的所有人。詹娜，列举一下。我们联系了兰迪·科德瑞，当然还有我们的摄影师马特·松恩、剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯、
Kate Flannery, Creed Bratton. And there was also a great breakdown with our writer, Danny Chun and our first AD, Kelly Cantley over on OfficeTele.com. And Angela, you got some tidbits from the DVD commentary. So without further ado, let's get started. Question number one, what was the inspiration for this cold open?
凯特·弗兰内瑞、克里德·布拉顿。我们的编剧丹尼·陈和第一副导演凯莉·坎特利还在OfficeTele.com上做了一次精彩的剖析。安吉拉，你从DVD评论音轨里也得到了一些花絮。废话不多说，我们开始吧。问题一，这个开场白灵感来自哪里？
Well first off, lip dubs were very popular at this time. Crazy popular. The idea was like you and a group of friends, or a lot of times coworkers actually, you would film yourself lip syncing to a song and it was supposed to happen all in one take but move to various locations. Yeah, I remember one that was going around that everyone was watching was a bunch of office coworkers at a company called Connect Adventures. And they filmed it one night after work and it was so fun.
首先，快闪在当时非常流行。疯狂流行。这个想法就是你和一群朋友，或者很多时候其实是同事，把自己假唱一首歌的过程拍下来，这本该是一气呵成的一个长镜头，但要在不同的地点转换。是的，我记得当时流传很广、人人都看的一段是一个叫Connect Adventures的公司的办公室同事们拍的。他们是在一天下班后拍的，超级有趣。
So guess what? The Dunder Mifflin gang wants to get in on this. Dunder Mifflin's lip dub starts with Andy in the elevator. He sings Nobody But Me, performed by the Human Beans. And he dances to the front door of Dunder Mifflin. Someone flips the blinds to read lip dub. Who's that person? Someone did. That would be Pam. The door opens and all of a sudden everyone is dancing in the bullpen. Erin is on roller skates. It goes all the way through the kitchen into the break room and back and it ends with confetti and everyone participates pretty much except for Daryl, Angela, and Stanley barely participates
所以你猜怎么着？邓德·米弗林的这帮人也想分一杯羹。邓德·米弗林的快闪从安迪在电梯里开始。他唱着《Nobody But Me》，原唱是Human Beans乐队。他跳着舞来到邓德·米弗林的前门。有人拨开百叶窗露出“Lip Dub”（快闪）的字样。那是谁？有人这么做了。那是帕姆。门开了，突然间所有人都在大厅里跳舞。艾琳踩着旱冰鞋。镜头穿过厨房一直走到休息室再转回来，最后以彩蛋告终，几乎所有人都参与了，除了达里尔、安吉拉，而斯坦利几乎没怎么参与
until the end. And Ryan uses it as an opportunity to promote woof.com. Right. I have to say, my favorite part of the lip dub is Kelly in front of the fan. In front of the fan. I just love it. I love Kate strapped to Brian's back, but we'll get to that. Okay.
直到最后。莱恩则趁机为woof.com打了个广告。对了。我必须说，我最喜欢快闪里的部分是凯莉在风扇前面。在风扇前面。我太喜欢了。我喜欢凯特被绑在布莱恩背上，但我们待会儿会聊到这个。好的。
Well, Danny Chun said the writers got the idea to do an office lip dub back in April or May before the summer break, before the end of season six. He said they'd been just watching lip dubs like we all were, but he thought, what I'd love to see is one that's kind of full of mistakes. Yeah. And he said that felt like a fun idea to play with. But Danny said they kind of forgot about the idea for a while, but when it came time to pitch on the season premiere, Danny brought it up again. On the DVD commentary, Danny said that this cold open lip dub was one of the most fun
丹尼·陈说，编剧们在4月或5月、暑假前、第六季结束前就萌生了拍办公室快闪的想法。他说他们当时就像我们大家一样一直在看快闪，但他心想，我希望能看到一个充满失误的版本。是的。他说这觉得是个很有趣的点子，可以拿来发挥。但丹尼说他们把这个点子忘了一段时间，不过当到了为季首播集构思方案的时候，丹尼又把这事提了出来。在DVD评论音轨里，丹尼说这个开场快闪是他经历过的最有趣的事情之一。
things he's ever been a part of. He said he wrote it in one day and it was originally supposed to start in the parking lot. And then it was going to come through the warehouse and end up in the office. But since none of those buildings are connected in real life, as you know, Jenna. Yes. They could not do it in one take. So our director, Jeff Blitz, suggested it all take place in the main office so that
他说他只用了一天就写好了，原本的设计是从停车场开始。然后穿过仓库，最后在办公室结束。但正如你所知，詹娜，现实中这些建筑并不连在一起。是的。他们无法用一个镜头拍完。所以我们的导演杰夫·布利茨建议所有场景都在主办公室发生，这样
we could do that whole one take look. That leads me into our next question, which was, how many takes did you have to do and was it really one take or was there some sneaky editing involved? Well guys, this kind of depends on who you ask. This was very funny. Everyone's memory was a little different on this one. According to Danny Chun, it was one long continuous take and we did it about three or four times. My memory was that it was one long take, and I remembered that we did three.
我们就能拍出那种一镜到底的效果。这就引出了我们的下一个问题：你们拍了多少条？真的是一个镜头到底，还是其中运用了什么巧妙的剪辑？伙计们，这其实取决于你问谁。这太搞笑。每个人的记忆在这个问题上都有点出入。据丹尼·陈说，那是一个长长的连续镜头，我们大概拍了三四条。我的记忆是那是一个长镜头，我记得我们拍了三条。
Angela, what did you remember? I remembered that it was all one long take as well because it was a domino effect of things. So I was there in Daryl's office and I had to shut the door, but me shutting the door cued Andy to say, go, go, go. So I just remember all of these moments and we did it all in one take, but I do remember that we got it pretty quickly. We were impressed with ourselves. We were like, oh my gosh, we got that. Yeah, same memory.
安吉拉，你记得是什么样的？我的记忆也是整个是一个长镜头，因为这是一个骨牌效应的过程。我在达里尔的办公室里，我得把门关上，而我关门的动作就是给安迪的 cue，让他喊：走，走，走。所以我只记得所有这些瞬间，我们确实是一气呵成拍下来的，但我也记得我们进展得挺快。我们当时还挺佩服自己的。我们心想，噢天哪，我们居然搞定了。是的，记忆一样。
Well, when we reached out to cinematographer Matt Stone, he confirmed that we did do this as one long continuous take. However, he said that they did work in a couple of spots where we could cut if we needed to, but we did shoot it as one long take. So then, when we reached out to our editor, Dave Rogers, he actually went back and checked his files. He said we did five takes.
当我们联系摄影师马特·松恩时，他证实我们的确是作为一个长长的连续镜头拍下来的。不过，他说他们在其中设置了几个如果需要可以剪辑的节点，但我们确实是当成一个长镜头拍摄的。然后，当我们联系我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯时，他真的回去检查了他的文件。他说我们拍了五条。
And he sent them to us. Amazing. He said we used a combination of take four and take five. So he said it's mostly all take five, but we cut when Angela slams Darryl's office door, and then we cut on the whip to take four as the camera moves by Phyllis dancing and heads into Michael's office
而且他把这些发给我们了。太棒了。他说我们用了第四条和第五条的结合。所以他说基本上全都是第五条，但在安吉拉摔上达里尔办公室门的时候剪辑了一下，然后在一个摇镜头时切到了第四条，当时镜头掠过跳舞的菲莉丝，进入迈克尔的办公室，
as he performs the magic tricks with his wand, and then we whip out back to take five as Andy yells, streamers. And then we stayed and take five until the end. And Dave said, looking at all the takes, he thinks the reason we did this was because Steve's magic in his office was best in take four, and they really wanted that magic take in the episode.
看他在里面用魔杖变魔术，接着一个摇镜头又切回第五条，安吉拉大喊：彩带！然后我们就保持在第五条直到结束。戴夫说，看了所有的素材，他觉得之所以这么做，是因为史蒂夫在他办公室里的魔术表演在第四条里表现得最好，他们非常想把那个精彩的魔术镜头放进剧集里。
I just have to give a big thank you to Dave Rogers because we all had different memories, and he had the answer. Yeah, thank you, Dave. Incidentally, in terms of Michael's magic, Danny Chun shared that they basically just gave Steve a bunch of dorky magic tricks and let Steve improvise it. So each of those magic takes in his office were a little bit different, except for the fire part. Yeah, they had a magician's helper named Amos Levkovich.
我必须对戴夫·罗杰斯表示大大的感谢，因为我们大家的记忆各不相同，而他掌握着标准答案。是的，谢谢戴夫。顺便说一句，说到迈克尔的魔术，丹尼·陈透露他们基本上就是给了史蒂夫一堆愚蠢的魔术道具，然后让史蒂夫即兴发挥。所以他办公室里的每一个魔术镜头都不太一样，除了玩火的那部分。对，他们请了一个叫阿莫斯·列夫科维奇的魔术师助手。
He was hiding behind Michael's door to preset that flame trick at the end. So here were all of Michael's tricks. A dove comes out of his wand, flowers appear out of his cane, and then of course that flame in his hand. I remember Steve loved that dove coming out of the wand. He did. And he does it like three times. I know. It's so funny. All right, let's see. Next question, how did they choose which song to use? Well, that was all Danny. It was the only song he considered. He said he really wanted a song that was, quote, short, upbeat, fun to lip sync to,
他躲在迈克尔的门后面，为最后那个火焰把戏做好了预设。迈克尔的所有把戏如下：魔杖里飞出一只鸽子，手杖里变出鲜花，然后当然就是他手里的那团火。我记得史蒂夫特别喜欢魔杖里飞出鸽子那一幕。他确实喜欢。而且他连着变了三次。我知道。太搞笑了。好吧，来看下一个问题，他们是怎么选定这首歌的？这全都是丹尼的主意。这是他考虑过的唯一一首歌。他说他真的很想要一首歌，用他的话说，“节奏短小、欢快、适合假唱，
and not too current. Randy said it cost us $50,000 to get the song rights. And we should probably add that we could really hear that song. They had speakers like hidden all around the set and it was really playing the song. We were really doing like lip syncing. Yeah. And I mean, I don't think you can fake that, that kind of energy that a song brings. I was so glad that they were playing it throughout the office. Yes.
而且不要太时髦”。兰迪说我们花了两万美元才买下这首歌的版权。我们或许还应该补充一点，我们在现场真的能听到这首歌。他们在布景周围藏了许多扬声器，音乐是真的在播放。我们真的是在假唱。而且我觉得，那种音乐带来的能量是假装不出来的。我很高兴他们一直在办公室里播放这首歌。是的。
Our next questions are, who came up with the choreography and what was the rehearsal process like? This was heavily choreographed, you guys. So the lip dub was choreographed by Mary Ann Kellogg. She planned it out with a team of dancers. They shared on the DVD commentary that every single detail you see was planned. Randy Cordray even sent us their rehearsal video. I loved watching it, Jenna.
接下来的问题是：编舞是谁想出来的？排练过程是怎样的？伙计们，这段舞蹈编排强度很高。所以这段快闪是由玛丽安·凯洛格编舞的。她和一帮舞者一起策划了这一切。他们在DVD评论音轨里分享说，你看到的每一个细节都是精心策划的。兰迪·科德瑞甚至给我们发了他们的排练视频。我看着太喜欢了，詹娜。
Me too. They had all these dancers doing our parts. Way better than we did them, by the way. Real dancers. They were amazing. The rehearsal dancers need a shout out. They were Tammy Toh, Lauren Marie Menendez, Michael Cothran-Penna, Jennifer Mimi Karsh, Erin Cash, and John Todd.
我也是。他们找了这些舞者来跳我们的部分。顺便说一句，比我们跳得好多了。真正的舞者。他们太棒了。这些排练舞者必须拥有姓名：他们是塔米·托、劳伦·玛丽·梅嫩德斯、迈克尔·科特兰-佩纳、珍妮弗·咪咪·卡什、埃琳·卡什和约翰·托德。
They were so great. We couldn't have done this without them. Randy Cordray said, we can put the rehearsal in our Insta stories so you guys can watch it. And Danny said they had scripted out all the beats, but there were little things that were tricky. For example, getting Erin from reception to the kitchen in time, or the fact that he wrote in the script that Meredith is strapped to Kevin's back in the break room.
他们太棒了。没有他们我们根本完成不了。兰迪·科德瑞说，我们可以把排练视频发到我们的Instagram快拍里，这样你们大家就能看到了。丹尼说他们把所有的节拍都写成了剧本，但其中有一些小细节非常棘手。比如，让埃琳准时从前台走到厨房，或者他在剧本里写了梅雷迪思在休息室里被绑在凯文的背上。
Oh yeah, he just wrote that down. Yeah. But how to make that happen. Exactly. Kelly Cantley shared that our special effects coordinator, Mike Thompson, built the harness that Kate had to wear. And you guys, I reached out to Kate because I was like, Kate, will you please tell me about being strapped to Brian's back? How did you do
哦对，他随手就写上去了。对。但怎么把这变成现实呢。没错。凯莉·坎特利透露，我们的特效协调员迈克尔·托ンプ森制作了凯特必须穿的背带。伙计们，我联系了凯特，因为我说：“凯特，求求你跟我讲讲被绑在布莱恩背上是怎么回事？你是怎么做到的？
it? What was the process? Here's what she had to say. Hey, it's Kate Flannery. Okay, so this is the deal. I was on a harness on Brian's back. There was a table behind us so that I wasn't putting all my weight on him the entire time. So I would squat on the table, even though it was high up, just to get my weight off of his back. Like, don't break another actor. Don't do it. Anyway, so he I'm on his back on this crazy harness. And then he turns around and I have the word nobody on my stomach. Okay, the first time we do it, it's perfect. The whole thing was perfect.
整个过程是怎样的？”她是这么说的。嘿，我是凯特·弗兰内瑞。好吧，情况是这样的。我绑在布莱恩背上的背带上。我们身后有个桌子，这样我就不用把全身的重量一直压在他身上。所以我蹲在桌子上，虽然位置挺高，但就是为了把我的体重从他背上卸下来。就像，别把另一个演员压垮了。别这么干。总之，我，我挂在他背上，绑着这个疯狂的背带。然后他转过身，我肚子上写着“Nobody”（无人）这个词。好吧，我们第一次排的时候，完美。整个过程完美无缺。
Like you guys, there's no cut in a lip dub. It has to be all one take. So everybody has to get their part right, everybody. And we did, except that they felt like my nobody was too faded. The marker had like absorbed into my skin. So I feel like I let everybody down. So we had to do, I think we did two more takes for safety, but I still feel like we would have had it on the first one if you could read my nobody. So my pasty white skin absorbed the Sharpie. It took a couple of days for it to come off, I'll be honest with you. It's kind of weird to look in the mirror when you're
就像伙计们，快闪里是没有剪辑的。必须是一气呵成的长镜头。所以每个人都得把自己的部分演对，每一个人。我们做到了，除了他们觉得我的“Nobody”字迹太淡了。马克笔的墨水好像渗进我的皮肤里了。所以我觉得我让大家失望了。于是我们不得不，我想我们为了安全起见又拍了另外两条，但我依然觉得如果能看清我的“Nobody”的话，我们第一条就成功了。所以是我苍白如纸的皮肤把马克笔墨水给吸收了。老实说，过了好几天才洗掉。洗澡或穿衣服照镜子的时候，
taking a shower or getting dressed and your stomach says, nobody. Don't try this at home, folks. But she said that nobody, they had to go back and ride it over and, you know, really darken it. And it was there for days. Well, I loved this day. I remember we came in early and we rehearsed. And then we went to hair and makeup. And I remember Randy told us we had the whole day, we should just take the day. Right, no stress. Yeah, and all the dancers were there. We watched their video and then whoever was dancing our part would show us our part. And show us the timing. Mm-hmm, yes.
看到自己的肚子上写着“Nobody”，感觉挺诡异的。大家千万别在家模仿。但她说那个“Nobody”，他们不得不回去重新描了一遍，而且涂得很深。结果好几天都没掉。不过我很喜欢那一天。我记得我们很早就来了，然后排练。接着去了化妆造型部。我记得兰迪告诉我们说我们有一整天的时间，可以慢慢来。对，完全没有压力。对，所有舞者都在。我们看了他们的视频，然后谁跳我们的部分就会教我们。教我们节奏。嗯，是的。
So Randy told me that yes, we started rehearsing at 7.15 in the morning. We got our first take at 11.23. That's the precision of Randy Cordray. He knows the exact moment. Yeah. He's like an air traffic controller. Your flight will leave at 712. Okay. Exactly. Okay. All right, Randy. And we wrapped for the day at 1 36. And it was just so much fun.
所以兰迪告诉我，没错，我们早上7点15分开始排练。我们在11点23分完成了第一条。这就是兰迪·科德瑞的精准度。他精确到每一分钟。他就像个空中交通管制员。你的航班将在7点12分起飞。好的。完全正确。好吧，兰迪。我们在下午1点36分收工。而且真的太好玩了。
That's an early wrap day for us, you guys. So that meant we had the whole afternoon. We were probably so excited. I know. I remember our biggest hurdle was that there was a big cleanup between each take with all the streamers and everything. But besides that, we were able to really go through those takes pretty quickly. Angela, I got a fan question from Ian O. in South Africa and Diana T. in Paris, France, to international folks who are wondering, Angela, were you bummed that you couldn't really participate in the Lipdub festivities?
对我们来说这是一个超早收工的日子，伙计们。这意味着我们整个下午都有空。我们当时肯定兴奋坏了。我知道。我记得我们最大的障碍是每拍完一条之后要清理一地彩带和其他东西。除此之外，我们能够非常快地把那些镜头过完。安吉拉，我收到了来自南非的伊恩·O和法国巴黎的戴安娜·T的粉丝提问，这两位国际朋友想知道，安吉拉，你有没有觉得很遗憾，因为你没能真正参与到快闪的狂欢中？
I mean, you know me in real life. I wanted to be on those roller skates. I wanted to zip through. I was so excited. It looks so fun. But it made sense that my character would not want to participate. But I still got to be in it. I was glad that at least I had that little moment with Darryl, and I yelled at the camera and slammed the door.
我是说，你了解现实生活中的我。我很想穿上那双旱冰鞋。我很想滑来滑去。我太兴奋了。看起来太好玩了。但我的角色不愿参与也合情合理。不过我还是参与进去了。我很庆幸至少我有那个跟达里尔在一起的小片段，我对着镜头大喊并摔上了门。
So we were in there the whole time. As the camera went past us into the kitchen, we got a little bit of a break. But I have a great memory of that day because it was pretty relaxing. I didn't actually have to do any heavy lifting in the lift up. I kind of got to watch it. And you know Craig is such an easy person to hang out with. We had a fun time. We were sort of like the goldfish in the glass bowl, like watching the humans go by. Jenna, what about you? Did you have fun? You got to dance and you love to dance. You got to do a
所以我们全程都在那里。当镜头从我们身边经过进入厨房时，我们稍微休息了一下。但我对那天有一个极好的回忆，因为相当轻松。我实际上不需要在快闪里干什么重活。我基本上是看着。你知道克雷格是个特别容易相处的人。我们过得很开心。我们有点像玻璃缸里的金鱼，看着人类从眼前走过。詹娜，你呢？你玩得开心吗？你得跳舞，而你又最喜欢跳舞。你还得扭一扭。但你得倒着走。那很难吗？那真的挺棘手。所以压力有点大，因为埃德和我得负责开头。如果我们开头的节奏不对，那就完蛋了。
shimmy. But you had to go backwards. Was that hard? That was really tricky. So it was a little stressful because Ed and I had to start it off. And if we didn't start off with the right timing, then forget it. We should just not even continue. And that's really me pulling the blinds. And then I had to dance backwards into a very specific spot where I'm hiding people behind me who can jump out. Yeah. So that was like a big choreography between me and Matt Sohn,
我们干脆就别继续了。那真的是我拉开百叶窗。然后我得倒着跳到一个非常具体的位置，在那里我把准备跳出来的人藏在我身后。对。所以这就像是我和我们的摄像师马特·松恩之间的一场盛大编舞，你可以看到我用眼角余光瞥了一眼，因为我担心往后退的时候会撞到前台的小椅子上。如果仔细看，我不得不看。我真的很怕撞上去。但我觉得所有这些时刻都正如丹尼所说的那样。这里是一家纸业公司。我敢打赌，如果我真的撞到椅子上，丹尼肯定会乐开花。他会觉得：太棒了，就这样。
our camera operator, and you can see me glance out of the corner of my eye because I was worried I was going to run into the little chair at reception when I'm going back. If you look closely, I had to look. I was really afraid I was going to run into it. But I think all of those moments were because exactly of what Dani said. This is like paper company. I bet Dani would have loved it if I ran into the chair. He would have been like, that's fine.
但是的，就像你说的，确实非常非常精心地编排过，除了最后，大家都在即兴发挥、跳舞、扔彩带之类的那些部分。所以到了那个地步我们才算松了一口气。说到最后那部分，我们还收到了新墨西哥州的塞西莉·G的一个粉丝抓包。在2分19秒时，我抓到了一个滑稽的约翰·卡拉辛斯基上下跳跃的画面。她说他在展现他的一些舞步。对，就像他在《迪斯科咖啡馆》里做的那种。我找了一下，真的很棒。
But yes, like you said, it was really, really choreographed, except at the end, that stuff of us were just improvising and dancing and throwing streamers and stuff. And so that was a relief once we got to that point. We also, speaking of that ending part, had a fan catch from Cecily G in New Mexico. At two minutes and 19 seconds, I have a cheesy John Krasinski jumping up and down catch. She said he's doing his bust out some of his dance moves. Yeah, the same kind of stuff he did in Cafe Disco. I looked for it and it's great.
我回头也得去看看。我对克里德弹吉他这一幕特别好奇。对。因为克里德经常来我家弹吉他。对。这人太厉害了。所以我联系了他，我说：“克里德，你当时真的是在弹那部分的曲子吗？
I'll have to go look for it. I was really curious about Creed playing the guitar. Yeah. Because Creed comes over to my house and plays a guitar all the time. Yeah. The man's amazing. So I reached out to him and I said, Creed, are you really playing that part of the song?
你真的在弹吉他吗？这到底是怎么回事？”他说，我当时……你真的是在弹那部分的曲子吗？你真的在弹吉他吗？这到底是怎么回事？他说，其实我并不是真的在弹。我只是在模拟按弦的手法看起来应该是什么样。而且看起来很真实，因为我确实会弹吉他，但我并没有跟音乐的节奏同步。哦，有趣。
Are you really playing the guitar? What's happening here? He said, and I are you really playing that part of the song? Are you really playing the guitar? What's happening here? He said, and I'm not actually playing that. I'm approximating what the notes would look like. And it looks real because I can actually play the guitar, but I'm not synced up to where the music would be. Oh, interesting. Yeah.
所以是由一个会弹吉他的真人在那假弹。我当时真的觉得他每一个音符都按得严丝合缝。对。我很佩服。好吧，我们的最后一个问题是：托比当时真的在摄像机后面，还是他的声音是后期加上去的？他的声音是后期加的。对。
So fakey playing by a real person who can play on a real guitar. It really looked to me like he was playing the notes exactly. Yeah. I'm impressed. Well, our final question is this. Was Toby really behind the camera or was his voice added in post? His voice was added in post. Yeah.
摄像机是由我们的摄影师马特·松恩操作的。我觉得保罗那天甚至都没站在摄像机后面。我没有这个记忆，保罗。对不起。你在吗？你太安静了。不过我挺喜欢他们让它变成托比的声音这个设计的，因为这样一来，整个办公室的全员都参与进来了。
The camera was operated by our cinematographer, Matt Sohn. I don't even think Paul was standing behind the camera that day. I don't have a memory of it, Paul. I'm sorry. Were you there? You're so quiet. I do love though that they made it Toby's voice because by doing that, then the whole entire office participated.
没错。没错。凯莉·坎特利分享说，她在拍摄时和马特一起在房间里走来走去。还有我们的收音师布莱恩·惠特尔，我完全记得这个。我记得。凯莉当时就好像……她手里拿着整个流程的大纲，还拿着秒表。她一直在说：我们走吧。对。
Yes. Yes. Kelly Cantley shared that she walked around the room with Matt while they were filming. Also our boom operator, Brian Whittle, and I totally remember that. I remember that. Kelly was like, it's like she had the outline of the whole thing and she had a stopwatch. She was like, let's go. Yeah.
他们就像一小撮人挤在一起那样移动。保持我们的节奏。但我们还有我们的第二副导演斯蒂芬妮，她藏在前台桌子后面。她负责给手势。我们的制片助理查克藏在柜台边的那扇门后面，以防有人走进去。我记得他会探出头来，在小伙子们从厨房回来时给个手势，好让我们准备好。这简直就是一架精密的机器。
They were like this little trio clump just kind of moving through. Keeping us on track. But we also had our second AD Stephanie hiding behind the reception desk. She was giving cues. Our PA Chuck was hiding behind that door over by a counter if nobody goes in. And I remember he would peek out and give the cue when the guys were coming back in through the kitchen so we could be ready. It was just, it was this whole machine.
对。有些舞者藏在暗处，用来提醒我们接下来该做什么。魔术师藏在暗处。天哪，我真希望我们能有幕后纪录片素材，记录下完成这一切到底动用了多少人。对。伙计们，非常感谢你们发来问题。剖析这些真的太有趣了。做这个节目太好玩了。我这周把这一集重看了好多次，詹娜。
Yeah. Some of the dancers were hidden to kind of remind us what we were supposed to do. The magician was hidden. Gosh, I wish we had like actual documentary footage of all the people it took to pull this off. Yeah. You guys, thanks so much for sending in your questions. That was really fun to break down. It was so much fun to do. I rewatched that so many times this week, Jenna.
每次看都让我很开心。我也是。我们能做这么有趣的事。我知道。我们太幸运了。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我得分享我在德州阿彻城寻找一台能播放蓝光光盘的DVD播放器所经历的坎坷旅程。
It made me happy every time. Me too. What a fun thing we got to do. I know. We were so lucky. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, I have to share the journey I went on to find a DVD player that could play a Blu-ray disc in Archer City, Texas.
安吉拉，我通过短信陪着你经历了那段旅程。你确实陪着我。那真是一段不小的旅程。确实。然后当然了，我们来聊聊裙带关系，因为天哪，这一集发生的事情也太多了。一些公司层面的惩罚。好吧，我们回来了。安吉拉，你得跟大家分享一下在德州看这张DVD的故事。为了提供一些背景，我想先做个铺垫。
I was on that journey with you, Angela, via text message. You were. And it is quite a journey. It is. And then of course, let's talk nepotism because, oh man, does a lot happen in this episode. Some corporate punishment. All right, we are back. And Angela, you have to share the story about watching this DVD in Texas. And for some context, I just want to say this to preface.
我们录制这个播客到现在已经整整三年了。整整三年了，女士。我真不敢相信我们录播客三年了。整整三年了，女士。我真不敢相信已经三年了。而且我依然对你为了一集的准备工作所付出的努力深感佩服，哪怕在没有现成工具的情况下也是如此。我是说，我真的为我们感到骄傲。我对你也有同感。我曾跟你通电话，当时你正躲在家庭聚会卫生间的马桶上，
We have been recording this podcast now for three years. Three years, lady. I can't believe podcast now for three years. Three years, lady. I can't believe it's been three years. And I am still so impressed at the lengths that you will go to prep an episode, even when you did not have the tools readily available. I mean, I'm just really proud of us. I feel the same way about you. I have talked to you while you have been hiding in a bathroom with your laptop while at like
试图抽点时间。试图抽点时间把工作做完。所以伙计们，我们太热爱做这个播客了，无论在哪我们都会坚持做下去。没错。所以这是我关于如何观看《裙带关系》DVD评论音轨的故事。我知道我当时会在我的家乡德州阿彻城，德州北部的一个非常小的镇上，根据最近的人口普查，人口是1601人。
a family reunion. Trying to get some time. Trying to get some time, some work done. So you guys, we love doing this podcast and we'll do it from wherever we can. That's right. So here's my story of how I watched the DVD commentary for nepotism. I knew I would be in my hometown of Archer City, Texas, very small town in North Texas, population according to the last census, 1,601.
在阿彻城每个人都认识每个人。每个人都认识每个人，而且大家都很乐意帮忙。所以，在我去之前，我问了我姐姐珍妮特，我说：“嘿，你有DVD套装吗？”她说：“哦，我哪儿有一套。”所以我就想，好吧。她说：“不，我知道它就在这儿。”我说：“好吧。所以我……好吧。她说：‘不，我知道它就在这儿。’我说：‘好吧。’所以我的姐姐找到了她旧的套装。
Everybody knows everybody in Archer City. Everybody knows everyone and they're all willing to chip in. So, before I went, I asked my sister Janet, I said, hey, do you have the DVD box set? She's like, oh, I have one somewhere. So, I was like, okay. She goes, no, I know it's here. I said, okay. So, my like, OK. She goes, no, I know it's here. I said, OK. So my sister finds her old box set.
詹娜，那是蓝光盘。蓝光旧套装，现在甚至都不生产了。对，我大约早上8点开始收到安吉拉发来的短信。我收到这样一条短信：“天哪，我姐有这个套装，但它是蓝光的，我们不知道怎么在我妈的DVD播放器上播放。”然后你写道，
Jenna, it was the Blu-ray. The Blu-ray old box set, they don't even make them anymore. Yes, I started getting texts from Angela about 8 in the morning. And I get this text, oh my god, my sister has the box set, but it's Blu-ray, and we can't figure out how to get it to work in my mom's DVD player." And then you wrote,
我觉得这玩意儿十年没用过了。哦不，确实没有。它们根本不兼容。它们不兼容。不仅如此，我们开始用旧遥控器，结果把我妈的DVD机彻底弄坏了。哦不。然后你当时有点……倒也不是恐慌，但你当时在想，我该怎么办？这是我的备采日。
I don't think it's been used in a decade. Oh no, it hadn't. They were not compatible. They were not compatible. Not only that, we started using old remotes, completely messed up my mom's DVD. Oh no. And you were like, now you're like a little, not panicking, but you're like, what am I going to do? This was my prep day.
所以接着我姐姐比利说：“过来吧，试试我的。”我收到了那条短信。8点30分。我姐姐比利有一个DVD播放器。我要去她家。对。然后就是一片死寂。直到11点30分我才听到你的消息，你说：“不行，那也不行。
Yeah. So then my sister Billy's like, come on over, try mine. I got that text. 830. My sister Billy has a DVD player. I'm going to head to her house. Yeah. And then it was like radio silence. I did not hear from you until 1130 when you said, nope, that didn't work.
正赶往小学。”我当时想：什么？对。发生什么事了？好吧。第三个地点。第三个地点。你说：“不行，那也不行。正赶往小学。”我当时想：什么？发生什么事了？第三个地点。第三个地点。我到了小学。我姐姐是个学校老师。
Headed to the elementary school. And I'm like, what? Yeah. What is happening? Okay. Third location. Third location. said, nope, that didn't work. Headed to the elementary school. And I'm like, what? What is happening? Third location. Third location. I get to the elementary school. My sister is a school teacher.
她当时在那儿为即将到来的新学年准备教室。她觉得：“也许这儿会有一个。”小学校长艾米为我开的门。她当时说：“安吉拉，我想我们在我的台式电脑上下载了一个能播放蓝光的程序。”她下载了一个程序。我知道。所以，
She was up there preparing her classroom for the upcoming school year. She was like, maybe there'll be one here. The principal of the elementary school, Amy, opened the door for me. She was like, Angela, I think we've downloaded a program that will work on my desktop to play the Blu-ray. She downloaded a program. I know. So desktop to play the Blu-ray." She downloaded a program.
我坐在小学校长的办公室里，结果还是不行。所以现在他们觉得：“好吧，去教室试试。”我走进了我姐姐的教室。现在体育老师克里莎、朱莉和另一个学前班老师米丽娅姆也在那儿。我们所有人都在试图弄好我姐姐的笔记本电脑。它就是不放。最后，图书管理员阿曼达前来救场，她说：“我觉得小学图书馆里有一个蓝光
I know. So, I sit in the elementary school principal's office and it didn't work. So now they're like, okay, let's try one of the classrooms. I go into my sister's classroom. Now PE teachers, Krissa and Julie and another pre-K teacher, Miriam, is in there. We're all trying to make my sister's laptop work. It won't play it. And then finally to the rescue, Amanda, the librarian, she says, I think we have a Blu-ray
光盘播放器。”但问题是，因为是暑假所以图书馆关门了，而且那天温度高达114华氏度（约45.6摄氏度）。那个图书馆超级热、超级闷，但他们把门打开了，你猜怎么着？真的行。它成功播放了蓝光盘，然后我在12点45分收到了你发给我的视频，安吉拉。这是你坐在那儿看DVD评论音轨四个小时后拍的，他们甚至还给你搬了个电风扇。你正坐在一台风扇前面。我坐在小学图书馆的小阅读角的地上。这就是我为这一集做备采的地方。
disc player in the elementary school library. But here's the thing, it's closed because it's summer and it was 114 degrees that day. That library was super hot and stuffy, but they opened it up and guess what? It did work. It played the Blu-ray and then I get this video of you, Angela, that you sent me at 1245. This is like four hours later of you sitting and watching the DVD commentary and they even brought you a fan. You're sitting in front of a fan. I'm sitting on the floor in the little reading nook of the elementary school library. And that is where I prepped this episode.
非常感谢阿彻城小学的女士们帮我看了《裙带关系》。太棒了。我那天对你的韧劲印象深刻，安吉拉。谢谢。感觉全镇都在帮你看DVD。所以我们将这一集的《办公室女士》
Thank you so much to the ladies at the Archer City Elementary School for helping me watch Nepotism. Amazing. I was very impressed with your tenacity that day, Angela. Thank you. It was like a whole town helped you watch the DVD. So we dedicate this episode of Office Ladies
献给德州阿彻城。谢谢。我注意到这一集开头有个地方，女士，《办公室女士》献给德州阿彻城。谢谢。我注意到这一集开头有个地方，女士，
to Archer City, Texas. Thank you. I noticed something at the very top of this episode, Office Ladies to Archer City, Texas. Thank you. I noticed something at the very top of this episode, lady. New opening credits! We added a bunch of new shots. They did this because it was our season premiere episode. We had these big, long, extended credits. We're gonna have shorter credits moving forward,
全新的片头字幕！我们加了好多新镜头。他们这么做是因为这是我们的季首播集。我们有这么长、这么大的加长版片头。接下来我们会换成较短的片头，
but we do keep these new shots of Michael Dwight, Pam Jim, Ryan, and Andy. And we will always end with Michael moving the Dundee on his desk. Here's a little bit of opening credits trivia I heard on the commentary. The commentary is already paying off. While sitting in the elementary school library,
但我们保留了迈克尔、德怀特、帕姆、吉姆、莱恩和安迪的新镜头。而且我们总是会以迈克尔挪动他桌上的邓迪奖杯结尾。这里有一点我在评论音轨里听到的片头小八卦。评论音轨现在就开始发挥作用了。坐在小学图书馆里时，
they shared that we will have new opening credits every time Dunder Mifflin gets a new boss moving forward. Oh. How about that? Okay. We'll be on the lookout for that. Yes. Well, Michael is gonna arrive to work and he has a talking head. He says sadly summer had to come to an end. You guys, a lot happened. He got West Nile virus, then he stepped on a piece of glass in a parking lot. That hurt. He peed on it, and he was surprised it got infected. And maybe he saw inception. I mean, what a summer. So under all of this, we see various shots of Michael, and one of them is a very simple
他们分享说，此后每当邓德·米弗林换新老板，我们就会换一次全新的片头。哦。怎么样？好吧。我们拭目以待。好的。好吧，迈克尔来上班了，他有一个访谈。他说夏天不得不结束，真是令人难伤心。伙计们，发生了好多事。他得了西尼罗河病毒，然后又在停车场踩到了一块玻璃。那可真疼。他在上面尿尿，结果没想到感染了。可能他还看了《盗梦空间》。我的天，真是丰富多彩的一个夏天。在所有这一切的背景下，我们看到了迈克尔的各种镜头，其中一个是向一棵秋树非常简单的
swish pan over to a fall tree, a tree with beautiful autumn colors. Yeah, that seems really out of place. It did. It seems like a big old fakie tree. Guess what, lady? What? It was a big old fakie tree. Okay.
摇镜头，一棵有着美丽秋叶的树。对，那看起来非常格格不入。确实。看起来就像一棵老旧的假树。你猜怎么着，女士？什么？那确实是一棵老旧的假树。好吧。
But it was in the script. There was a script note that came along with Michael's talking head that said this, Michael gets out of his car, something catches his eye. He looks over at a tree with brilliant autumn colors. He sighs, forlorn, if not angry. Oh my goodness. At this autumn tree. What a narrative. Well, Randy Cordray said to get this autumn tree was quite an ordeal. Just this little
但剧本里写了。迈克尔的访谈旁边附带着一则剧本注释，上面写着：迈克尔从车里出来，有什么东西吸引了他的视线。他望向一棵色彩绚烂的秋树。他叹了口气，落寞甚至有些恼火。哦天哪。对这棵秋树。多么有故事感。好吧，兰迪·科德瑞说为了弄到这棵秋树可真是一场折磨。仅仅是这一个小小的
script note. He said, we shot this on August 2nd in 2010. There were no trees with fall colors to be found anywhere in the United States of America, anywhere. They couldn't fly one in from anywhere. You are kidding. Nothing in Vermont? I don't know. Did the trees start changing that early, early August?
剧本注释。他说，我们是在2010年8月2日拍摄的。美国境内根本找不到任何一棵呈现秋色的树，哪儿都没有。他们没法从任何地方空运一棵来。你在开玩笑吧。佛蒙特州也没有吗？我不知道。树叶八月初就开始变色了吗？
I am the last person to ask that question. I'm sure there's listeners in Vermont right now going, lady, lady. He said there is a place that you can go in Hollywood. It's called Green Set. And they have amazing trees, shrubs, and landscaped decor for any budget. And they have fakey fall trees. I went on their website. Once again, I was clearly meant to be some sort of props or set deck in another life.
我是最后一个能回答这个问题的人。我敢肯定现在佛蒙特州有听众在喊：“女士，女士！”他说好莱坞有一个地方你可以去。它叫绿景（Green Set）。他们有适合任何预算的惊艳树木、灌木和景观装饰。他们有假秋树。我上了他们的网站。再一次，我显然在另一生里注定是搞道具或布景的料。
They have fakie box hedges and real box hedges. This place, in addition to fakie hedges, also has animal statues, like you can rent. What? Yeah, like, come on. If you want to put a big tiger in your yard, they also have glacier walls. What? Like, if you're doing, I don't know if you're doing a movie or something,
他们有假黄杨树篱和真黄杨树篱。这个地方除了假树篱，还有动物雕塑，你可以租。什么？对，就像，拜托。如果你想在院子里放大老虎，他们还有冰川墙。什么？就好像如果你在拍，我不知道如果你在拍电影什么的，
and you need to look like you're standing in front of a glacier, or if you have a theme party about ice climbing. I'm getting so excited. I mean, if you guys ever take Office Ladies on the Road, please use that as stage backdrops. Like a giant glacier wall? Yeah, depending on what state you're in. Or the tiger.
需要看起来像是站在冰川前面，或者如果你有一个关于攀冰的主题派对。我太激动了。我是说，如果你们《办公室女士》以后去巡演，请把那个当成舞台背景。比如巨大的冰川墙？对，取决于你在哪个州。或者是老虎。
Yes. Oh my gosh, that's amazing. And then everyone can see what we were talking about in this episode. Here's your glacier wall. Now, I just want to say, I'm still talking about this tree, because in addition to having to find this fakie tree, Randy said there was more, just for this little swish shot.
太棒了。然后大家就能看到我们在这一集里一直在讨论的东西了。这就是你们的冰川墙。现在，我只想说，我还在谈论这棵树，因为除了得找到这棵假树，兰迪说还有更多要求，就为了这么一个简单的摇镜头。
What more? He said they had to shoot very early in the morning. Okay. And they had to rent a special light to backlight this tree. It was called a 10K. It has 10,000 watts of light. Just for this one sentence in a script. Yes, because they wanted it to look like it was early morning sun coming through the colorful
还有什么？他说他们必须在清晨很早的时候拍摄。好吧。而且他们不得不租用一种特殊的灯来给这棵树打逆光。那叫10K灯。它有1萬瓦的亮度。就为了剧本里的这一句话。是的，因为他们希望看起来像是清晨的阳光穿过色彩斑斓的
leaves to highlight these leaves and set them apart from everything around them. This is that moment as a writer where I'm like, do you think Danny was like, oh, we could have lost the autumn tree. You know what I mean? Exactly. I didn't know it was all that much work. Well that's Randy's job is is to go through the script. And then I think sometimes he'll have to go to production.
树叶，来突显这些树叶，并让它们从周围的一切中脱颖而出。这就是作为编剧的那个时刻，我会想：你觉得当时丹尼会觉得“哦，其实我们可以不要这棵秋树”吗？你知道我的意思吗？完全没错。我不知道原来要费这么多功夫。好吧，兰迪的工作就是仔细阅读剧本。然后我觉得有时候他不得不去找制片部门。
He'll be like, OK, here's the thing. You can either have your lip dub song or the autumn tree. Pick. I mean, I don't have the budget for all of it. Or sometimes he finds a way to make it all work, which is amazing. Which is usually the case. So what happens next, Ange?
他会说：“好吧，情况是这样的。要么你们要快闪的歌，要么要秋树。二选一。”我是说，我可没有预算把这些全搞定。或者有时候他会想办法让所有事情都行得通，这真的很了不起。通常情况确实如此。那接下来发生什么了，安吉？
Andy is going to be chatting up Aaron and then Gabe walks in? Yes, we find out that Aaron and Gabe have started dating over the summer. Gabe says it has been an a word, exquisite. Then Aaron has a talking head that sounds like she only said yes because she thought she had to because Gabe was her boss, which makes me real sad. Yes, but now she seems to enjoy her relationship with him. It seems. It seems.
安迪打算去跟艾琳搭讪，然后盖布走进来了？对，我们发现艾琳和盖布在夏天开始约会了。盖布说那是一个A开头的词，精致。然后艾琳有一个访谈，听起来她答应只是因为她觉得身为主管的盖布是她不得不答应的，这让我觉得好难过。是的，但现在她似乎挺享受和他的关系的。看起来是这样。看起来是这样。
Andy has a talking head where he says, he's all right with it. He's on a nice beach at Cape Cod gazing out across the Whitecaps. That's his anger management. That's right. But oh, look, it's a humpback whale who's eating Gabe. Well, I also watched in the elementary school library the deleted scenes and there were a ton of deleted scenes where everyone shares what they did over the summer. Oh, it was a much bigger runner. One is hilarious. I'm going to save and share it later. Okay. Hint, hint. It's about Kevin.
安迪有一个访谈，他说他对此觉得还好。他正身处科德角的一处美丽海滩上，眺望远处的白浪。那是他的情绪管理。没错。但噢，看呐，是一头正在吃盖布的座头鲸。好吧，我还在小学图书馆里看了删减片段，里面有超级多删减片段，每个人都在分享他们夏天都干了什么。哦，那是一段长得多的副线剧情。其中一个太搞笑了。我要留到待会儿分享。好吧。给个提示。是关于凯文的。
Well, Pam is adjusting the thermostat and Dwight comes up and locks it up. Yeah, he says if she's so hot, she can just sit on an ice pack. Thanks Dwight. Can we talk about the hydration backpack that Dwight has on? He requires hands-free hydration, Angela. I know. I looked it up. It's called a Camelback hydration pack. They have many options of these online. And I'm quoting the internet here, with minimal storage space, this pack is best for quick hikes or trail runs that
好吧，帕姆在调恒温器，德怀特走过来把它锁上了。对，他说如果她觉得这么热，大可以坐在冰袋上。谢谢你，德怀特。我们能聊聊德怀特身上背着的那个补水背包吗？他需要解放双手的水分补给，安吉拉。我知道。我查过了。这叫Camelback（骆驼）补水背包。他们在网上有很多这种款式可供选择。我引用一下网上的介绍：“由于存储空间极小，这款背包最适合不需要大量装备的快速徒步或越野跑。”
won't require a ton of gear. And the two-liter reservoir capacity ensures you'll have enough water for your trip. Danny said something on the commentary that really made me laugh. He said, I wish that Dwight had worn that camelback backpack for the rest of the season. I was like, oh man, me too. I see people with those on all the time when we're skiing. Oh. And honestly, I think next season I'm going to get one. Yeah. Because you got to stay hydrated on the slopes, lady.
两升的储水量确保了你的出行有充足的水。丹尼在评论音轨里说了一句话把我逗得哈哈大笑。他说：“我真希望德怀特在接下来的一整季里都背着那个骆驼补水背包。”我当时想：天哪，我也是。我看到滑雪的人经常背着那种背包。哦。老实说，我觉得下个季度我也要买一个。对，因为你在雪道上必须保持水分充足，女士。
And there's nowhere to put a bottle of water. Please tell me if you wear one of those that you'll take a picture and send it to me. Because I need that image in my life. Dwight has my favorite talking head of this episode. He says, Dwight Schrute, star salesman, beat farmer, bed and breakfast proprietor, aspiring freelance bodyguard, add to that list owner of this building, then burn the list.
而且根本没地方放水瓶。如果你背了那个东西，请一定拍张照片发给我。因为我的脑海里需要这个画面。德怀特有本集我最喜欢的访谈。他说：“德怀特·舒鲁特，王牌销售员，甜菜农，民宿老板，有志成为自由职业保镖，再加上一条：这栋大楼的业主，然后把这张纸烧掉。”
And then he takes a big swig out of the little hose. He looks like a four-year-old with a sippy cup. He really does. I love Kelly's talking head. Oh, and talk about a new look. Oh, yeah. Corporate sassy Kelly. Well, the reason for that for that lady is because she did
然后他从那个小软管里猛吸了一大口水。他看起来就像个拿着学饮杯的四岁小孩。真的太像了。我喜欢凯莉的访谈。哦，说到新造型。哦，是的。职场女强人凯莉。好吧，之所以有这种转变，是因为她
the minority executive program at Yale. She says you don't even know how smart I am now. You could ask her to name the biggest company in the world and she would be like blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah giving you the exact right answer. Brilliant. So good. Brilliant. Our writers are brilliant. We had a fan catch from Leah J. in Charleston, Indiana, who said, at 5 minutes 36 seconds, the whiteboard behind Kelly says, meeting with Chris, Nick, and Ed.
去耶鲁参加了少数族裔高管项目。她说你们甚至不知道我现在的脑子有多聪明。你可以问她世界上最大公司是哪一家，她就会“巴拉巴拉巴拉”地把完全正确的答案报给你。太绝了。太棒了。我们的编剧太才华横溢了。我们收到了印第安纳州查尔斯顿的莉亚·J的粉丝抓包，她说：“在5分36秒时，凯莉身后的白板上写着：与克里斯、尼克和埃德开会。”
Is that referring to Nick the IT guy? And who are Chris and Ed? Oh, hold up. That's our camera crew. Yes, Chris and Ed were our assistant camera operators and our sound guy was Nick Carbone. Yep. Well, now we are going to meet Luke. Luke's gonna show up with the coffee. He's gotten everyone's order wrong. Well, I was very surprised and I paused to make sure that we used real Starbucks cups.
这是在指IT男尼克吗？那克里斯和埃德又是谁？噢，等等。那是我们的摄像机组。对，克里斯和埃德是我们的摄像助理，我们的收音师是尼克·卡博内。没错。好吧，现在我们要去见卢克了。卢克拿着咖啡走过来了。他把所有人的订单都弄错了。好吧，我当时非常惊讶，我还特意暂停确认我们用的是真正的星巴克杯子。
Those were Starbucks. Yeah. How did we get away with that? I asked Randy about it and he said that at first this was flagged by standards and practices because if you want to use a real product, you have to clear it with the NBC ad sales department. Because if they had an advertiser who might be a competitor, then that person who had bought ad time would definitely not want to see free advertising on a show. Right.
那是星巴克。对。我们是怎么过审的？我问过兰迪，他说一开始这个被标准与实践部门标记了，因为如果你想使用真实的商业产品，你必须通过NBC广告销售部门的审批。因为如果他们有一个竞争对手的广告商，那么那个买下广告时段的人绝对不会愿意在节目里看到免费广告。对。
Like if you're the guys at Pete's Coffee. Yeah, or Coffee Bean. You're like, hey, hold on a second. Hey, get that Starbucks out of there. Well, I guess coffee chains were not actually huge ad buyers at the time. What? Really? Yes. Wow.
就像如果你是皮茨咖啡（Peet's Coffee）的人。对，或者咖啡豆（Coffee Bean）。你会想：“嘿，等一下。嘿，把那个星巴克拿走。”好吧，我猜当时的咖啡连锁店其实并不是买广告的大户。什么？真的吗？是的。哇。
That's what Randy said. That's how old we are. That's how old the show is. Yes. We had flip phones. There was no Instagram and coffee companies weren't that big of a deal. Yeah. And so I guess there were no conflicts
兰迪是这么说的。这就是我们有多老。这就是这部剧有多老。是的。我们当时用的是翻盖手机。没有Instagram，咖啡公司也不是什么大不了的事。对。所以我想当时没有什么利益冲突，
and we were able to get approval to use real Starbucks cups. Wow. You know about the whole Starbucks cup on the set of Game of Thrones that made it into the Game of Thrones episode. I do. I can't believe they haven't gone back and like wiped that out.
我们得以获得批准使用真正的星巴克杯子。哇。你知道《权力的游戏》片场里那个穿帮的星巴克杯子吧，它甚至还留在了正片里。我知道。我真不敢相信他们到现在还没回去把那个用数字擦掉。
It's not like such a lore of the show that it's like an Easter egg. You're just going to keep it in. Winter is coming and so is your Starbucks. There's now a series of talking heads that are really funny, but basically the theme is everyone hates Luke and that Luke sucks. Yeah, in the kitchen, Andy is going to confront Michael and just say, Luke is the worst. He needs to be fired, Michael. But Michael's just kind of hedging. He's like, he's not that bad.
这倒不是剧里那种类似彩蛋的宏大背景设定。你只需要顺其自然就行。“凛冬将至，你的星巴克也是。”现在有一系列非常搞笑的采访镜头，但基本的主题就是大家都讨厌卢克，觉得卢克太糟糕了。对，在厨房里，安迪要去找迈克尔对质，直接说，卢克是最差劲的。他得被开除，迈克尔。但迈克尔却有点支支吾吾的。他觉得，他没那么坏。
That other intern we had was worse. Lady, I need to talk about this. Did you notice Steve's holding an apple in his scene? He's got a coffee in one hand and an apple in the other. I went to the script. I'm like, did this apple have a story? No, it's just, I guess he went to the kitchen to get an apple.
我们之前招的另一个实习生更差劲。天哪，我得聊聊这个。你注意到史蒂夫在镜头里拿了个苹果吗？他一只手拿着咖啡，另一只手拿着苹果。我翻了剧本。我想，这个苹果有什么剧情吗？没有，就是，我猜他去厨房拿了个苹果吧。
I thought it was interesting. This is like an interesting. Why is Michael holding an apple? Interesting choice. Well, I mean, I don't know, apple and coffee. Sounds gross to me. We are now gonna start a whole storyline that is really centered around Pam at the core.
我觉得挺有意思的。这就像是个挺有意思的细节。为什么迈克尔要拿个苹果？挺有趣的安排。好吧，我是说，我不知道，苹果配咖啡。听起来真恶心。我们现在要开启一条全新的故事线，核心完全围绕着帕姆。
Dwight has this impressive ring of keys. I mean, it's ridiculous. It's huge. He has all these keys and Jim is doing basically classic Jim prankage. Yes. Jim has a bunch of extra keys in his desk. When he gets Dwight to go check for raccoons in the wall, he tries to add a few extra keys to the key ring.
德怀特有一大串让人印象深刻的钥匙。我是说，太夸张了。太巨大了。他有这么多的钥匙，而吉姆基本上在做经典的吉姆式恶作剧。没错。吉姆的办公桌抽屉里有一堆备用钥匙。当他让德怀特去检查墙里有没有浣熊时，他试图往钥匙串上加几把额外的钥匙。
His goal is very similar to when he was putting the nickels in Dwight's phone receiver. Oh, amazing. It's my favorite prank, personally. Me too. Mm-hmm. He's going to put so many extra keys, like one a day, two a day, onto this key ring that eventually his pants will fall down. That was his goal.
他的目标跟之前把硬币塞进德怀特电话听筒里时非常相似。噢，太棒了。这绝对是我最喜欢的恶作剧。我也是。嗯哼。他打算在钥匙串上加超多备用钥匙，比如一天加一把，或者一天加两把，直到最后德怀特的裤子会掉下来。这就是他的目标。
Well, Jim has a talking head that said, what happened to me this summer? Dwight bought the building. So actually, this has been the busiest summer of my life. Yeah, he had to make plans. Lots of prank plans. Pam finds it hilarious and starts laughing, and Dwight busts Jim.
好吧，吉姆有个单采镜头说，我这个夏天发生了什么？德怀特买下了这栋大楼。所以实际上，这是我一生中最忙碌的一个夏天。对，他得做计划。制定好多恶作剧计划。帕姆觉得这太爆笑了，开始大笑，然后德怀特当场抓包了吉姆。
Yeah. We had a fan question from Sarah C. in Lubbock, Texas. Does Rain throw real keys at John's head or are they fakey keys? One of them hit him. And you hear like a thump. Well, I know. I was wondering the same thing. I swear they were real keys. Same.
对。我们收到了来自得克萨斯州拉伯克的萨拉·C的粉丝提问。雷恩是真的把钥匙朝约翰的头上扔，还是用的假钥匙？其中一把打到他了。然后你还能听到“咚”的一声。好吧，我知道。我也在想同一件事。我发誓那是真钥匙。我也是。
Because I have this memory, Rain was kind of throwing them at John's chest in the scene. But then I swear it was this take. One of them just accidentally kind of like flew at John's head and they stopped. And John was like, dude, and Rain was like, I'm so sorry. He's like, it's okay, but like those are real. And yes, so I totally have that memory of shooting that scene. I think they're real too.
因为我有这样的记忆，雷恩在那个镜头里本来是把钥匙朝约翰的胸口扔的。但接着我发誓就是在这个镜头里。其中一把钥匙不小心就朝约翰的头部飞过去，然后他们停了下来。约翰当时说，老兄，雷恩就说，我太抱歉了。他说，没事，不过那些可是真的。所以没错，我完全有拍摄那个场景的记忆。我觉得那也是真钥匙。
I have the same memory. And also if you watch John's reaction. That's what I mean. Yeah. Well, you know, this is interesting because Pam feels really bad and Jim is bummed out that his prank didn't go. And BJ talked on the commentary about how they had to get creative with conflict scenes for Jim and Pam now that they're a happily married couple.
我也有同样的记忆。而且如果你观察约翰的反应的话。我是说这个。对。好吧，你知道，这很有意思，因为帕姆觉得非常内疚，而吉姆则为自己的恶作剧没能成功而感到沮丧。BJ在评论音轨里谈到了，对于吉姆和帕姆来说，既然他们现在是一对幸福的已婚夫妇，他们必须在冲突场景的设计上发挥创意。
I thought it was really interesting. Let's listen. So this was something we thought of because we like when Jim and Pam have stories, but we don't want to invent fights. They're a couple that gets along really well. And we like stories between them, but we don't always want them having conflict because that's not real so what would be a light conflict right real but not sad yeah is that interesting that they had to find ways for Jim and Pam to have storylines and this sort of Pam trying to do right by Jim with this prank was one of those light conflict storylines well we also had a fan catch from Ashley W.
我觉得这真的很有意思。我们听听看。所以这是我们想出来的一个点子，因为我们喜欢吉姆和帕姆有自己的故事，但我们不想凭空捏造争吵。他们是一对相处得很好的伴侣。我们喜欢他们之间的故事，但我们不希望他们总是产生冲突，因为那不真实。所以，什么是轻松的冲突呢？真实却不悲伤。对。这不是很奇妙吗？他们必须为吉姆和帕姆寻找推动剧情线的方法，帕姆试图通过这个恶作剧来顺着吉姆的心意，就是这些轻松冲突的剧情线之一。好吧，我们还收到了来自俄克拉荷马州的阿什利·W的一个粉丝发现。
in Oklahoma for the scene. You're gonna like it, Angela. Okay. Here's what Ashley said. Pam's desk plant has a bow on it. It's like a gift bow. Are these plants gifts from someone? Does she have a plant subscription box?
关于那个场景。你会喜欢的，安吉拉。好的。阿什利是这么说的。帕姆办公桌上的绿植上系着一个蝴蝶结。就像礼品盒上的那种蝴蝶结。这些植物是别人送的礼物吗？难道她订购了植物盲盒订阅服务吗？
Maybe that's why they were constantly changing. Wait, is there such a thing as a plant subscription box? I've never heard of that. Could I get plants sent to me every month? You've never heard of this? No. It's like, you know, like cheese of the month. You can get flowers of the month, plant of the month, wine of the month.
也许这就是它们经常换的原因吧？等等，真的有什么植物盲盒订阅服务这种东西吗？我从来没听说过。我可以每个月都有人给我寄植物吗？你从来没听过这个？没有。就像那种，你知道的，类似于“按月订购奶酪”一样。你可以订购“按月订购鲜花”、“按月订购植物”、“按月订购红酒”。
Okay, cheese, wine. I guess flowers make sense, but I didn't know you could get a whole living plant like in a pot. I mean, I believe it. I want one. Okay, plant subscription box. Come in your way, lady. Josh is going to be like, Ange, plants are all over the house.
好吧，奶酪、红酒。我猜送花还算说得过去，但我不知道你还能收到一整盆活的植物。我是说，我相信有这回事。我也想要一个。好吧，植物盲盒订阅服务。正向你走来，女士。乔什肯定会说，安琪，家里到处都是植物。
I had a flowers of the month. Lee got it for me for Christmas one year and every month I got fresh flowers. It was so amazing. What a great gift. I know. Well, I'll tell you what, Ashley. I don't know if there was a subscription box, but I'll tell you my backstory for that plant. Do you remember when Jim let Pam's plant die on her desk when she went on maternity
我曾经有过“按月订购鲜花”的服务。有一年圣诞节李给我订了这个，每个月我都能收到新鲜的鲜花。真是太棒了。多棒的礼物啊。我知道。好吧，我告诉你吧，阿什利。我不知道是不是有什么订阅服务，但我来告诉你我对那盆植物的背景故事设定。还记得当帕姆去休产假时，吉姆任由帕姆桌上的植物死掉的那件事吗？
leave? So you think Jim bought Pam a new plant? I do. Oh, I like that. And that's why there was a little bow on it. And I think she didn't take the bow off because it reminded her of Jim's thoughtfulness. I like that. Well, there is someone in the office who you don't want to tick off and that is Phyllis.
所以你觉得是吉姆给帕姆买了一盆新植物？我是这么觉得的。噢，我喜欢这个解释。所以这就是为什么上面系着一个小蝴蝶结。而且我觉得她没有把蝴蝶结解下来，是因为它能让她想起吉姆的体贴。我很喜欢这个。好吧，办公室里确实有一个你绝对不想惹毛的人，那就是菲利斯。
Oh, that's right. And Luke has crossed Phyllis. She lost an account because she's pretty sure Luke did not send the samples he was supposed to. That's right. Lehigh Motors has not gotten their samples. He blows off Phyllis, and then, you know, he's just like playing video games on Meredith's computer.
噢，没错。而且卢克惹恼了菲利斯。她丢了一个客户，因为她非常确信卢克根本没有寄出本该寄出的样品。没错。里海汽车公司还没有收到他们的样品。他把菲利斯晾在一边不管，然后，你知道的，他只顾着在梅雷迪思的电脑上玩电子游戏。
Everyone's getting so frustrated with Luke, Michael sends him to get ice cream. At eight minutes and 49 seconds, Angela, you are not at your desk in the background of the scene. I noticed. I thought I had gone to the bathroom. Where have you sneaked away to, lady?
每个人都对卢克感到越来越沮丧，迈克尔打发他去买冰淇淋。在视频第8分49秒时，安吉拉，背景里根本看不到你在办公桌旁。我注意到了。我当时以为我去洗手间了。你到底溜去哪儿了，女士？
I probably talked our AD into letting me go to the bathroom. Like, they're not gonna see me. I know. All right, we are 10 minutes into this episode and we are gonna move to a scene in the conference room I noticed with the conference table. Yeah. Not the usual row of chairs. Table is back.
我可能说服了我们的助理导演让我去上个洗手间。就那种，反正他们也拍不到我。我知道。好了，这集已经播了10分钟了，我们要转到一个会议室的场景，我注意到会议桌居然在。对。不是平时那种一排排的椅子。桌子又摆出来了。
People are gonna figure out pretty quickly that Michael is related to Luke. Oscar accuses Michael of nepotism. This whole conference room scene is delicious and amazing. During this re-watch, lady, I love our conference room scenes. Same. I loved doing our conference room scenes. I used to feel bad for Steve because I knew how much work they were for him.
大家很快就会发现迈克尔和卢克有亲戚关系。奥斯卡指责迈克尔搞裙带关系。整个会议室的戏码妙趣横生又精彩绝伦。在这次重看过程中，女士，我太喜欢我们的会议室戏份了。我也是。我超爱拍我们的会议室戏份。我以前挺心疼史蒂夫的，因为我知道这些戏对他来说工作量有多大。
We'd be in there all day, and he would be the leader. He would be driving the scene. He would have the majority of the dialogue. And all we had to do was chime in with a line or two here. And basically everyone that worked at Dunder Mifflin was always versus Michael. Yes. But they are delightful. I get so excited every time we go to the conference room. At 10 minutes and 19 seconds in this conference room scene, Rain is drinking water from his pouch. I swear to God I remember that he drank real water from that pouch all day long. I remember he had to pee all day
我们得在那呆上一整天，而且他是核心领头羊。得由他来推动整个剧情。大部分台词都在他身上。而我们只需要在一旁偶尔插上一两句台词就行。基本上所有在邓德米弗林工作的人都是在和迈克尔作对。是的。但这些戏真的太精彩了。每次我们走进会议室，我都兴奋得不行。在这场会议室戏份里，在第10分19秒时，雷恩正在用他的袋子喝水。我发誓我绝对记得他一整天都在用那个袋子喝真水。我记得他一整天都要上厕所
long. No, it's true. He was not fakey drinking. He was not fakey drinking. Rain is very method, you know, as an actor. So if he was like, if Dwight's supposed to be drinking water, I'm going to be drinking lots of water. Yeah. Creed has a talking head that I absolutely love. Creed says, I couldn't care less about nepotism, but I'm loving the debate.
不，真的。他不是在假装喝水。他真的没有在假装喝水。雷恩是个极其注重体验派的演员，你知道的。所以如果他觉得，如果德怀特应该在喝水，那他就会喝大量的水。对。克里德有个单采镜头，我简直爱得不行。克里德说，我才不在乎什么裙带关系呢，但我太喜欢这场辩论了。
Great minds battling it out, and I've got a front row seat. So good. So good. I mean, I'm Creed. Really? I'm loving it as well. Well, lady, maybe we should take a break. Yeah, and when we come back, Luke
伟大的头脑在激烈交锋，而我就在前排拥有专属座位。太棒了。太棒了。我是说，不愧是克里德。真的吗？我也超喜欢。好吧，女士，也许我们该休息一下了。对，当我们回来时，卢克
is going to have soy ice cream and bagel chips for everybody. And there was a mini Michael Pam tangent that was cut from this conference room scene that I'm excited to share. Ooh. Well, we are back from break. Michael is continuing to defend Luke. He's even comparing himself and Luke to like God and Jesus. That's right. And Jim has this line where he says, oh, so you and Luke are God and Jesus. And Michael says, no, not that.
要给每个人分发大豆冰淇淋和贝果脆饼干。而且这个会议室场景里其实有一段简短的迈克尔和帕姆的小插曲被剪掉了，我非常高兴能和大家分享。噢。好吧，我们休息回来了。迈克尔继续为卢克辩护。他甚至把他和卢克比作上帝和耶稣。没错。然后吉姆说了这么一句，哦，所以你和卢克就是上帝和耶稣咯。迈克尔说，不，不是那样的。
I'm just saying, why does God get to do something I don't? Why does God get to do nepotism, basically? And then Oscar says, this is all hypothetical. We're talking about Luke, who is actually terrible. And I don't know if you noticed, lady, but 11 minutes, 48 seconds, when Oscar says that line to Michael, I'm sort of smiling and shrugging. Like I have a sort of out of context body energy. Yeah, like reaction.
我只是在说，凭什么上帝能做一些我不能做的事？为什么上帝可以搞裙带关系，基本上就是这个意思。然后奥斯卡说，这都只是假设。我们在说卢克，他实际上糟糕透顶。我不知道你有没有注意到，女士，但在11分48秒时，当奥斯卡对迈克尔说那句台词时，我其实在微笑和耸肩。就好像我有一种脱离语境的身体语言能量。对，就像是一种下意识的反应。
And at first I thought, oh my gosh, am I breaking? And then I remembered, no, Pam and Michael had a bit because I suddenly had that like sense memory of shooting it and we were laughing like all these memories came back. So I checked the shooting draft and I found it. Here is what would have happened. So Michael was going to say, why does God get to do something I don't? And then Pam says, Michael, you've built yourself up fair and square.
起初我还想，噢天哪，我是不是笑场穿帮了？然后我想起来，不对，帕姆和迈克尔之间其实有个小包袱，因为我突然有了拍摄那场戏的肌肉记忆，我们当时都在笑，所有的记忆都涌上来了。于是我查阅了拍摄剧本，我找到了。以下是原本会发生的剧情：迈克尔本来会说，凭什么上帝能做一些我不能做的事？然后帕姆会说，迈克尔，你现在拥有的一切都是靠你自己堂堂正正争取来的。
How can you support favoritism like this? To which Michael said, Pam, let's say you're my daughter, and I'm the CEO of the world's biggest toy company, Scott's Games and Fun. We make funny putty, magic marbles, connectables. And Dwight said, what are connectables? And Michael said, they're my knockoff Legos, almost as good, half the price. And I remember that was, we would lose it on this, like, connectables, like, what are
你怎么能支持这种偏心？对此迈克尔说，帕姆，假设你是我的女儿，我是全世界最大的玩具公司“斯科特游戏与乐趣”的CEO。我们生产滑稽橡皮泥、神奇弹珠、拼插玩具。德懷特说，什么是拼插玩具？迈克尔说，这是我的山寨乐高，几乎一样好，只要半价。我记得那是，我们当时笑得肚子疼，就像，拼插玩具，就像，什么是
connectables? Yeah. So anyway, then Michael would say, okay, one day I fall in the slime-inator and die. And we would all laugh. Like we could not get through this runner of Michael's toy company. Oh my god, I'm remembering this because I remember also how well thought out it was. He's throwing it out as just an off the cuff example, but it is a well thought out toy company.
拼插玩具？对。总之，然后迈克尔会说，好吧，有一天我掉进黏液机里死了。我们都会大笑。就像我们根本无法顺利演完迈克尔玩具公司的这个桥段。天哪，我想起这个是因为我也记得当时这个设定有多么深思熟虑。他只是顺口随性地举了个例子，但这是一个考虑周全的玩具公司。
Yes. He says, Pam, I left you the company. Would you turn it down? So in this example, Pam is Michael's daughter. And Michael's created this insanely successful toy company. But he dies in the slime-inator and has left her the company. He's Willy Wonka. He wants to know, would I turn it down? And Pam said, if I was unqualified, yes.
是的。他说，帕姆，我把公司留给你。你会拒绝吗？所以在这个例子中，帕姆是迈克尔的女儿。迈克尔创建了这家疯狂成功的玩具公司。但他死在了黏液机里，把公司留给了她。他是威利·旺卡。他想知道，我会拒绝吗？帕姆说，如果我不胜任，会拒绝。
To which Michael says, very seriously, but you're not. You've got an amazing mind for toys. And then the script said, Pam looks flattered. And then Oscar said, this is all hypothetical. So that look on my face. But also why Oscar is saying this is all hypothetical. Yes, this toy company. But it's Oscar is saying this is all hypothetical.
对此迈克尔非常严肃地说，但你很胜任。你有着惊人的玩具头脑。然后剧本写道，帕姆看起来受宠若惊。然后奥斯卡说，这全都是假设。所以我的表情是那样。但这也是为什么奥斯卡要说这全都是假设。是的，这家玩具公司。但奥斯卡是在说这全都是假设。
Yes, this toy company. But it's why when I'm sitting next to him on that line, I'm like, oh, well, thank you very. You can see that I'm saying non-verbally, thank you very much, Michael. Like Pam is like, oh, well, if you say so. That's right. Oh my gosh, I remember all of that now.
是的，这家玩具公司。但这也就是为什么当我在那句台词旁边坐着时，我会想，哦，非常感谢。你可以看到我在用非语言表达，非常感谢你，迈克尔。就像帕姆在说，哦，好吧，如果你这么说的话。没错。哦天哪，我现在全都想起来了。
Yes, right? It's like you opened a folder in my brain. Mm-hmm, mm-hmm. Yes, Michael's toy company. And by the way, I went to the bloopers to see if it was in there because I know it wasn't in deleted scenes. It's not in there, but we were cracking up.
对吧？就像你打开了我大脑里的一个文件夹。嗯嗯，嗯嗯。是的，迈克尔的玩具公司。顺便说一句，我去看了搞笑花絮，想看看里面有没有，因为我知道删减片段里没有。里面没有，但我们当时笑疯了。
There's somewhere. Somewhere. Well, that was delightful trip down memory lane. I do want to address something though with Pam. Oh. She's about to address something though with Pam. Oh, she's about to have a talking head where she says she feels awful for blowing Jim's prank. Can we talk about how fancy fancy Pam is looking? What is with this hair? I noticed black eyeliner. I mean, fancy Pam. You are not the only one, Angela. We got mail about it. We got a fan
总会在哪里的。某处。好吧，那是一次令人愉快的追忆之旅。不过我确实想谈谈关于帕姆的一些事。哦。她接下来要针对帕姆谈点事。哦，她马上要有一个面对镜头的独白，说她觉得自己搞砸了吉姆的恶作剧，感觉糟透了。我们能谈谈精致的帕姆看起来有多惊艳吗？这发型是怎么回事？我注意到了黑色眼线。我是说，精致的帕姆。安吉拉，你不是唯一一个这么想的。我们收到了关于它的邮件。我们收到了一个粉丝
question from Kaylee E in Indianapolis and Kristin H from Little Rock, Arkansas. Pam's look takes a big shift this season. Straighter hair, a tucked-in shirt, more blazers than cardigans. Surely there were many meetings about this? Surely there were. Surely. Surely. Surely. Surely there were. Surely. Yes, there were many meetings about this. Starting in wardrobe, I will tell you, we decided that we wanted Pam to keep her blazers,
来自印第安纳波利斯的凯莉·E和阿肯色州小石城的克里斯汀·H的提问。这一季帕姆的造型有了很大的转变。更直的头发，扎进裤腰的衬衫，西装外套比开衫更多。关于这一点肯定开了很多会吧？肯定开过。肯定的。肯定的。肯定开过。肯定开过。是的，关于这个开了很多会。从服装开始，我告诉你，我们决定让帕姆保留西装外套，
but we wanted to bring back more of what they would call Pam's color palette. So rather than having a dark shirt with a dark blazer, we wanted to bring the pastels back because that really felt like Pam. The pinks and the lighter colors. The light purple. Yeah. So you're going to see that. And then in terms of the hair, I went to Kim Ferry and I said,
但我们想带回更多他们所谓的帕姆的色彩搭配。所以比起深色衬衫配深色西装外套，我们想把粉彩色带回来，因为那才真正让人觉得是帕姆。粉色和较浅的颜色。浅紫色。是的。所以你会看到这一点。然后至于发型，我去找了金·费里，我说，
Kim, I miss Pam's hair. I miss the Pam mullet. The half up, half down? Yeah. And you know, we were changing Pam's hair because Pam's life was going through a lot of changes. She broke up with Roy. She started dating Jim. She got this new job at Michael Scott paper company. She became a mom. And you also just change your look over the years. You do. You do. Unless you were my grandmother who had the same hairstyle her whole life. Same with my grandmother, but Pam, Pam is evolving.
金，我想念帕姆的头发。我想念帕姆的鲻鱼头。那种半扎半放的发型？对。你知道的，我们改变帕姆的发型是因为帕姆的生活经历了许多变化。她和罗伊分手了。她开始和吉姆约会。她在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司得到了这份新工作。她成了一名妈妈。而且你随着岁数增长也会改变你的造型。确实会。确实会。除非你是我的奶奶，她一辈子都是同一个发型。我奶奶也是，但帕姆，帕姆在蜕变。
Well, I don't know about you, but in my life, I have always kind of had like a base hairstyle and I'll stray from it, but then I'll come back to it and I'll stray and I'll come back to it. And I felt like it was time for Pam to come home to her base hairstyle. But we also thought she's learned a lot about hair since that first frizzy half up, half down.
好吧，我不知道你们怎么样，但在我的生活中，我总是有一种基础发型，我偶尔会偏离它，但随后我会回归它，然后又偏离，又回归。我觉得是时候让帕姆回归她的基础发型了。但我们也觉得，经历了第一次那个毛躁的半扎半放发型之后，她对头发已经学到了很多。
And so now she's sleek half up, half down. That's right. Well, I thought you looked beautiful. You and Pam looked fantastic. Well, I also got married over the summer, and I had grown my hair out a little bit. I don't know. I could tell how happy I am in my life
所以现在她是顺滑的半扎半放。没错。好吧，我觉得你看起来很美。你和帕姆看起来棒极了。好吧，我夏天也结婚了，我的头发留长了一点。我不知道。我能看出我在生活中有多快乐
when this episode came on. And I feel like you can tell that newlywed No, I could tell how happy I am in my life when this episode came on. And I feel like you can tell that newlywed energy in this episode and moving forward. Well, Michael is gonna get a text and looks out the window. Angela is waving at him. She looks hot to trot to come down to the parking lot. Her first line to him, made me laugh, lady.
当这集播出的时候。我觉得你能看出那种新婚——不，我能看出我在生活中有多快乐，当这集播出的时候。我觉得你能看出这一集以及接下来的剧集里那种新婚的活力。好吧，迈克尔接到了一条短信，然后向窗外看去。安吉拉正在向他挥手。她看起来急不可耐地想来到停车场。她对他说的那第一句话，把我逗笑了，女士。
She says, I came down here to feed the feral cats like I usually do, and I found something unsavory in the back of your nephew's car. What was it? All of the things that he was supposed to be like mailing and shipping, Mm-hmm. Including Phyllis's samples. Mm-hmm. Oscar's expense reports. And some pants that Michael wanted to return to Talbot's. By the way, we got a fan catch from Mandy M. in Texas. OK.
她说，我来这里是为了像往常一样喂野猫，我在你侄子的车后备箱里发现了一些难闻的东西。是什么？所有他本该去邮寄和托运的东西，嗯——哼。包括菲莉丝的样品。嗯——哼。奥斯卡的费用报销单。还有迈克尔想要退给塔尔博特的裤子。顺便说一句，我们收到了来自德克萨斯州曼迪·M的粉丝抓包。好的。
Who said this, I have been holding onto this for so long. Mini deep dive alert. Oh, I'm loving Mandy. OK, Mandy, let's have it. Erin asked Michael about returning pants to Talbot's. Talbot's stopped carrying men's clothing in 2008 according to the New York Times. This episode aired in September 2010, two years after Talbot stopped carrying men's clothing. This must be another instance of Michael wearing women's clothing, which is an amazing callback to the negotiation.
谁说的这个，我把这个憋了好久了。迷你深度解析警报。哦，我太喜欢曼迪了。好吧，曼迪，请说。埃林问迈克尔关于在塔尔博特退裤子。根据《纽约时报》的报道，塔尔博特在2008年就停止销售男装了。这一集在2010年9月播出，在塔尔博特停止销售男装两年后。这一定是迈克尔穿女装的又一个例子，这是对那次谈判的绝妙呼应。
Oh, it's the first thing I thought of. I thought he's bought another woman's suit. Yes, without any pockets. And shoulder pads. Exactly. Michael is going to get on a video call with Joe and for the majority of this call, all you see is Gabe's crotch. Until Joe is like, well, you've been down, so I don't have to look at your crotch.
哦，这是我想到的第一件事。我想他又买了一套女式西装。是的，还没有口袋。还有垫肩。没错。迈克尔将与乔进行视频通话，在这通电话的大部分时间里，你看到的只有盖比的裤裆。直到乔说，好吧，你把镜头调低点，这样我就不用盯着你的裤裆看了。
Oh, I wrote out what she said because her line read on that was so funny to me. She says, lower yourself, Gabe. I don't want to be having a conversation with your crotch. I loved it so much. Angela, this reminded me of the day that we were working on our book over FaceTime. You remember? Yeah, yeah. We would have this like FaceTiming writing sessions. But do you remember that time? We were like two hours into the FaceTime and I look over and I realized that you've been like looking up my nose the entire two hours. You did not say anything.
哦，我把她的话写了下来，因为她那句台词的读法对我来说太搞笑了。她说，把镜头调低点，盖比。我不想对着你的裤裆聊天。我太喜欢了。安吉拉，这让我想起了我们通过FaceTime工作的那天。你记得吗？ yeah， yeah。我们会有那种FaceTime写作会议。但你还记得那次吗？我们FaceTime了大约两个小时，我抬头一看，意识到你这两个小时一直在看我的鼻孔。你什么都没说。
I didn't say anything. We were busy both typing and writing, but I would check in with you and for two hours, the way you had your laptop sort of positioned, I just saw your neck and up your nose. I mean, for two hours. I was like, lady, this could have been a phone call. Why are we on a video chat if you're looking at my chin, nose? It was crazy. I know. I didn't say anything, but it did remind me of whenever I FaceTime my mom and I see her
我什么都没说。我们俩都在忙着打字和写作，但我会查看你的情况，两个小时里，由于你放置笔记本电脑的角度，我只能看到你的脖子和你的鼻孔。我是说，整整两个小时。我想，女士，这本来可以打个电话解决的。既然你在看着我的下巴和鼻子，我们为什么还要进行视频聊天？这太疯狂了。我知道。我什么都没说，但这确实让我想起了每当我跟妈妈FaceTime时，我看到她的
forehead and ceiling fan. I'm like, mom, tilt it down. During this Skype when, this exchange also made me laugh, when Joe says, why won't you fire Luke? And Michael says, I love him. She goes, oh no, how far has it gone? Yeah. How far has it gone? Her line read on that, I mean, I rewound it.
额头和吊扇。我就说，妈，把镜头往下调。在这场Skype通话中，这段对话也把我逗笑了，当乔问，你为什么不解雇卢克？迈克尔说，我爱他。她说，哦不，进展到什么程度了？是啊。进展到什么程度了？她对这句台词的演绎，我是说，我倒回去听了。
I watched it like four times. I know. It's so brilliant. The woman is brilliant. And Michael's like, he's my nephew. And Joe's like, I have a nephew too, but he doesn't work for me. He'd screw it up. She says he can come swim in her pool,
我看了大概四遍。我知道。太精彩了。这个女人太绝了。迈克尔说，他是我侄子。乔说，我也有个侄子，但他不为我工作。他会搞砸的。她说他可以来她的泳池游泳，
but he can't come in her house. And Michael says, well, this is my pool. And he wants his nephew to work in his pool. And then Joe says, well, that's fine, but it's on you, Michael. If he screws up, I'm going to hold you accountable, basically. So Michael is going to have a talking head about how he's trying to work side by side with Luke. After this talking head, Jenna, there was a deleted scene that didn't make it in.
但不能进她的屋子。迈克尔说，好吧，这是我的泳池。而且他想让他的侄子在他的泳池里工作。然后乔说，好吧，那没问题，但这由你负责，迈克尔。如果他搞砸了，我基本上要找你算账。所以迈克尔接下来有一段独白，讲述他如何试图与卢克并肩工作。在这段独白之后，珍娜，有一个没有播出的删减片段。
It's on the DVD set. Michael calls his half sister, Luke's mom, to ask her advice on how to deal with Luke. I also went to the shooting draft because I wanted to know more about it. This is how it starts in the shooting draft. Michael is on the phone with his sister, Marnie. Okay. So we know her name, Marnie.
它在DVD套装里。迈克尔打电话给他的同母异父姐姐、卢克的妈妈，向她征求如何处理卢克的建议。我还去翻了拍摄初稿，因为我想了解更多。拍摄初稿是这样开始的。迈克尔正在和他的姐姐玛尼通电话。好的。所以我们知道了她的名字，玛尼。
He looks at his computer, which we don't see, and he says to Marnie, I'm so psyched you approved my friend request, Marnie. Oh look, we have Nana in common. And Marnie says she posts constantly. The scene continues. I have it from the DVD. I want you to hear it. Oh. Hey, how's Luke doing? Oh, best nephew ever. Isn't he? He really, he changes the whole demeanor of the office.
他看着他的电脑，我们看不到，他对玛尼说，我太高兴你通过了我的好友请求，玛尼。哦看，我们有娜娜这个共同好友。玛尼说她经常发动态。场景继续。我有DVD里的版本。我想让你听听。哦。嘿，卢克最近怎么样？哦，最棒的侄子。对吧？他真的，他改变了整个办公室的氛围。
It's really such a joy having him here. He's really a joy. Oh, good. I just wanted to ask you a parenting question. A parenting question? How do you deal with his? What? How do I deal with what, Michael? No, no, he's great. He's fantastic. It's just, you know when he has... he does this little attitude thing? What attitude? No, not attitude in a negative way. I'm talking like pink. You know how pink has an attitude or when a fashion photographer says give me more attitude
有他在真的很开心。他真的是个开心果。哦，太好了。我只是想问你一个育儿问题。育儿问题？你怎么处理他的？什么？我怎么处理什么，迈克尔？不，不，他很好。他太棒了。只是，你知道当他有……他有这种耍小脾气的毛病？什么脾气？不，不是负面意义上的脾气。我说的是范儿。你知道那种时髦范儿或者当时尚摄影师说给我更多范儿的时候
That's what I'm talking about He's great. He has a big he just has a lot of Attitude it's great Okay. All right. Well, I'm glad it's working out. It's great. He is such a joy and a pleasure and a real gem Okay, great. Well, you're the best, Michael. Well, thank you. That is awfully nice of you to say.
我说的就是这个。他很好。他很大牌，他只是很有范儿。这很棒。好吧。好吧。很高兴事情进展顺利。太棒了。他真是一个开心果、开心果和真正的宝贝。好吧，太棒了。好吧，你是最棒的，迈克尔。好吧，谢谢。你这话说的太好了。
And I just posted something on your wall. Okay, thanks for saying I'm the best. Love your brother, Michael. There it is. Give Luke a hug for me. I'll give him a hug and a kiss. Just a hug. That's good. All right.
我刚在你的墙上发了一条动态。好吧，谢谢你夸我是最棒的。爱你的哥哥，迈克尔。好了，就是这样。代我给卢克一个拥抱。我会给他一个拥抱和一个吻。只要一个拥抱。那就好。好了。
How amazing is that? It's my favorite thing I've ever heard. I mean, you hear how well it starts and then how badly it ends. It's so good, lady. So many layers. All right. Coming up is something I've also wanted to share with you.
这太神奇了吧？这是我听过的最喜欢的东西。我的意思是，你听听它开头多好，然后结尾有多糟。太棒了，女士。有太多层含义了。好了。接下来是我也一直想和你们分享的东西。
It's about Kevin and Pam by the elevators. Yes, Pam is going to do a very elaborate prank. She is rearranging the buttons on the elevator, and then she's going to have Dwight, I guess, try to use this elevator. And she's going to film them, and it's going to have Dwight, I guess, try to use this elevator. And she's going to film him and it's going to be hilarious because the elevator isn't going to do what you tell it to do. Kevin is rearranging the buttons.
是关于电梯旁的凯文和帕姆的。是的，帕姆要做一个非常精心设计的恶作剧。她正在重新排列电梯里的按钮，然后她打算让德怀特，我猜，试着坐这个电梯。她要拍下他们，她打算拍下他的视频，这会非常搞笑，因为电梯不会按你指令运行。凯文正在重新排列按钮。
He is the elevator technician. And we got a fan question from Leslie S. in San Francisco, California that says, I've always been confused by Pam's choice to ask Kevin to help her change the elevator button controls. Does he have some background as an electrician? I feel like Pam could figure this out more competently than Kevin. I mean, she did assemble a copier by herself. Exactly.
他就是电梯技术员。我们收到了来自加州旧金山的莱斯利·S.的一位粉丝提问，上面写着：“我一直对帕姆选择让凯文帮她改电梯按钮控制感到困惑。他有什么电工背景吗？我觉得帕姆自己搞定这个可能比凯文更靠谱。我的意思是，她确实自己组装过一台复印机。”没错。
And also, is Pam not worried when Kevin says, let me look at the circus board? Yeah, exactly. Well, this was the much bigger storyline for Kevin that I hinted at earlier in the episode. It explains why Kevin is helping Pam with the elevator panel. He shares in a talking head that over the summer, he decided to practice lying more. Oh.
而且，当凯文说“让我看看电路板”时，帕姆难道不担心吗？对，没错。好吧，这就是我之前在剧集里暗示过的凯文那条大得多的故事线。它解释了为什么凯文要帮帕姆弄电梯面板。他在面对镜头独白时透露，夏天的时候，他决定多练习说谎。哦。
Yeah, and he really got into it. I thought you were going to say over the summer he became an electrician. Oh, no, no, no. He just has decided to lie a lot. Here, listen. What? Oh. Well, last night, Jenny came over again. She cooked me dinner, and then we had sex all night long. Gross. That's awesome, Kevin. It is.
对，而且他真的很沉迷其中。我还以为你要说他夏天成了电工呢。哦，不，不，不。他只是决定狠狠地撒谎。听听这个。什么？哦。对了，昨晚珍妮又来了。她给我做晚食，然后我们整晚都在做爱。真恶心。太棒了，凯文。确实。
This summer, I decided to become a liar. I just make things up. It's going great. That is amazing. Yeah, so he starts off lying and accounting, then he has this talking head saying that he's now a liar. It's working out great. And then he tells Pam what he's going to do to the elevator and then lies some more.
今年夏天，我决定当个骗子。我就是凭空捏造。进展顺利。这太神奇了。是的，所以他从会计方面的谎言开始，然后他有了一段独白，说他现在是个骗子。进展非常顺利。接着他告诉帕姆他要对电梯做什么，然后又撒了更多谎。
Here, listen. How did you learn how to do this? Before this job, I worked as an elevator repairman. I specialized in the buttons. Hey, did you SMS text message me? I just came from the museum where I saw an exhibit on rare coins. I've never worked as an elevator repairman. That's another lie. It's become a tangled web. I'm a bit worried I'm losing myself. That is amazing.
听听这个。你是怎么学会这个的？在这份工作之前，我当过电梯修理工。我专门负责按钮。嘿，你给我发短信了吗？我刚从博物馆出来，在那里看到了一个稀有硬币的展览。我从来没当过电梯修理工。那是另一个谎言。这已经变成了一张错综复杂的网。我有点担心我正在迷失自我。太神奇了。
Well, what we see in the episode is Dwight just coming in and saying, Pam, I received your SMS message, old tech alert. Mm-hmm. What does she want? Lady, we could not get through this. There was something about the way Rain was entering as Dwight, sucking on his water. And Brian and I, you know that thing where like Rain wasn't in on it because
好吧，我们在剧中看到的是德怀特走进来，然后说：“帕姆，我收到了你的短信，老科技警报。”嗯哼。她想要什么？女士，我们简直录不下去了。雷恩扮演德怀特时，吸着他的水瓶进来的那个样子有点不对劲。我和布莱恩，你知道那种情况吗，就是雷恩并没有加入其中，因为
me and Brian had had this whole thing like you just played of him explaining the circuit board what he was doing. And then Dwight walks in and it just made us laugh. And Rain was like, what? What? What? Why can we not continue? OK, so the blooper for this is on the blooper reel for this season. But we were doing that laughing theme
我和布莱恩刚才在排练刚才你播的那段——他解释电路板以及他在做什么的戏。然后德怀特走进来，这直接把我们逗笑了。雷恩就说：“什么？什么？什么？为什么我们不能继续？”好吧，所以这个NG镜头在这个季度的NG花絮里。但我们当时在做那种大笑
where we're not making any noise. Right. There's no point in playing it because it's just two people shaking. Exactly. But you know what? I'll post it so people can see it. But anyway, eventually we get through this moment
但不出声的主题。对。放这个毫无意义，因为这只是两个人在发抖。没错。但你知道吗？我会把它发出来，让大家看看。不过不管怎样，我们最终还是熬过了这一刻
and Pam says to Dwight that she wants to show him something in the lobby. And she gets in the elevator with him. She starts filming him. Oh, she's so excited. She's so tickled by this. Well, at first it works. You know, it starts going up instead of down. But then the elevator gets stuck.
帕姆对德怀特说，她想在大厅给他看个东西。然后她和他一起进了电梯。她开始拍他。哦，她太兴奋了。她对此感到开心极了。好吧，一开始它确实起作用了。你知道的，它开始往上走而不是往下走。但接着电梯卡住了。
And Dwight immediately pees in the corner. Immediately. He isn't like, oh, maybe I can hold it for a little bit. It's like elevator doors don't open. What if they had opened two minutes later, mid-pee? Oh my gosh. He says, I have 56 ounces of fluid in my bladder. This made me curious.
然后德怀特立刻在角落里尿了。立刻。他可没有想“哦，也许我能稍微忍一下”。就像电梯门打不开一样。如果两分钟后门打开了，正好在尿尿的过程中呢？我的天。他说：“我的膀胱里有56盎司的液体。”这让我很好奇。
How much can a bladder hold? Did you Google that? I did. And I will tell you, according to Healthline, a healthy adult bladder can hold up to 16 ounces or two cups of urine. Dwight says he has 56 ounces of urine in his bladder. That's like five times more than a normal bladder. I didn't stop my search there.
膀胱能装多少液体？你谷歌过吗？我查了。我会告诉你的，根据Healthline的数据，一个健康的成年人膀胱最多可以容纳16盎司或两杯尿液。德怀特说他的膀胱里有56盎司的尿。这比正常膀胱大五倍左右。我的搜索并没有就此停止。
Just so you know, I became very curious. Because we have to pee all the time, lady. I know, it's healthy. Here was one of the questions in this article. Is it safe to hold your pee? What did it say? It said that if you have a healthy urinary system, holding your pee generally isn't dangerous.
为了让你们知道，我变得非常好奇。因为我们总是得去上厕所，女士。我知道，这是健康的。这篇文章里的其中一个问题是：憋尿安全吗？它上面写了什么？它说如果你有健康的泌尿系统，憋尿通常并不危险。
But in certain circumstances, holding your urine for any length of time can be dangerous, like if you have one of the following conditions, enlarged prostate, neurogenic bladder, kidney disorders, or urinary retention. So then don't hold it. Okay. Do you know what happens to your body when you hold your pee? Oh god, no. It says when you feel the urge to empty your bladder, it isn't just because your bladder is filling up with liquid. It's actually a really complex
但在某些情况下，长时间憋尿可能是危险的，比如如果你有以下某种情况：前列腺肥大、神经源性膀胱、肾脏疾病或尿潴留。所以那就别憋着。好吧。你知道当你憋尿时你的身体会发生什么吗？哦天哪，不知道。它说当你感到需要排空膀胱的冲动时，不仅仅是因为你的膀胱正在被液体填满。实际上这是一个非常复杂的
process that involves a bunch of muscles and organs and nerves, and that this reaction gets set off in your body when your bladder is only about half full. So that's why you can hold it for a bit. Oh, because your bladder's like warning. Yes. Warning. Exactly.
过程，涉及一堆肌肉、器官和神经，当你的膀胱只有大约一半满时，这个反应就会在你的身体里触发。所以这就是为什么你能憋一会儿。哦，因为你的膀胱在发出警告。是的。警告。没错。
Halfway full. Mm-hmm. And these signals kind of differ from person to person. And according to your age or if you've had a kid, these nerves and whatnot can maybe... And the who's he wasn'ts. Yeah. And the whatnots might be different. That's exactly right.
半满状态。嗯哼。这些信号因人而异。根据你的年龄或者你是否生过孩子，这些神经什么的可能会……还有那些七七八八的东西。是的。这些杂七杂八的东西可能会有所不同。完全正确。
Also, the signals will decrease at night. And that's why you can... Sleep, but you wake up having to pee. That's right. Because it won't signal you when your bladder's only half full. But you know what you should do if you really need to hold your pee. Here are some tips if, I don't know, lady, we need to hold it. Well, there's always some road trip where I have to hold it because there was no gas station.
另外，这些信号在夜间会减弱。这就是为什么你可以……睡觉，但醒来时不得不去上厕所。没错。因为当你的膀胱只有半满时，它不会给你发信号。但如果你真的需要憋尿，你知道你应该怎么做吗。如果，不知道，女士，我们需要憋尿，这里有一些小贴士。好吧，总会有某种公路旅行，我必须憋着，因为没有加油站。
Here's what it says. Number one, do a task that will actively engage your brain, such as a crossword puzzle. Well, I can't do that in the car. I'll get nauseous. It says listen to music. I can do that. Also, if you are already sitting, stay sitting. Don't stand up. Don't stand up.
它是这么说的。第一，做一件能积极调动你大脑的任务，比如填字游戏。好吧，我在车里做不了这个。我会晕车的。它说听音乐。这个我可以。另外，如果你已经坐着了，那就继续坐着。别站起来。别站起来。
Don't stand up. Oh yeah, cross your legs. You could read a book. Can't do that in the car. Listen to this one. This is a suggestion. Scroll through social media on your phone. That'll help you not have to go to the bathroom.
别站起来。哦对，把腿交叉起来。你可以看一本书。在车里看不了。听听这个。这是一个建议。在手机上刷社交媒体。那会帮你不用去洗手间。
All of these things are gonna make me sick in the car. Another thing is try to stay warm because being cold will give you the urge to urinate. Any wonder I always feel like I have to pee. I'm always cold. Yeah. Ah, well you know, lady, when I do my cold dip, so I sit in really warm water and then I go to my cold dip.
所有这些都会让我在车里感到恶心。另一件事是试着保持温暖，因为寒冷会让你产生排尿的冲动。难怪我总是觉得我想尿尿。我总是觉得冷。是的。啊，好吧，你知道的，女士，当我做冷水浴时，我坐在非常温暖的水里，然后我去泡冷水浴。
Do you have to pee? Yeah, when you get in the cold dip, it's like 60 degree water and it gives you this feeling like you have to pee even if you just peed. Whoa. Mm-hmm. I was going to ask you, have you ever been swimming in the ocean? Anyone?
你得尿尿吗？对，当你泡进冷水浴时，大约是60度的水，它会给你一种你想尿尿的感觉，即使你刚刚才尿过。哇。嗯哼。我要问你，你有没有在海里游过泳？任何人？
This is open for anyone. Have you ever been swimming in the ocean and you have to pee and you tell your body, go pee, it's okay. We're in the ocean, we floated away from other people, go pee." And your body's like, uh-uh, not doing it. My body won't pee in the ocean. I think it's the waves. I think it's just a weird thing. Sensation. You've told your body, don't pee in the pool, don't pee in the pool.
这向所有人开放。你有没有在海里游过泳，然后你想尿尿，你告诉你的身体，去尿吧，没关系。我们在海里，我们漂离了其他人，去尿吧。”然后你的身体说，呃-呃，不干。我的身体不会在海里尿尿。我觉得是海浪的问题。我觉得这是一种奇怪的感觉。触感。你已经告诉你的身体了，别在泳池里尿尿，别在泳池里尿尿。
Don't pee in the bath. Don't pee in the bath. And then you get in the ocean, you're like, have at it. And your body's like near I think it's the waves because I don't have a problem peeing in a lake. Oh When we go to Lake of the Ozarks and will like anchor the boat and you're in a cove and you're swimming you swim away from everyone else or You know when you're younger you pee right next to your sibling and you know, like what's that? Wait, can you guys pee in the ocean?
别在浴缸里尿尿。别在浴缸里尿尿。然后你进了海里，你就想，尽管来吧。然后你的身体好像在附近，我觉得是海浪的原因，因为我在湖里尿尿就完全没问题。哦。当我们去奥沙克湖时，我们会把船抛锚，你在一个小湾里游泳，你游到离其他人很远的地方，或者你知道的，当你年轻的时候，你就在你兄弟姐妹旁边尿尿，你知道的，那是怎么回事？等等，你们能在海里尿尿吗？
Oh yeah. You got no problem? So Jenna, that rules out your- Sam and Cassie- Yeah, we're both excellent peers over here. ... and pee in the ocean. That rules out your wave theory, your scientific wave theory. Listen, that was, I was certain that's what it was.
哦，是的。你完全没问题？所以詹娜，这就排除了你的——萨姆和卡西——对，我们俩都是这里绝对的尿尿高手。……然后在海里尿尿。这就排除了你的海浪理论，你的科学海浪理论。听着，那，我当时确信那就是原因。
It was the waves of the ocean as well. Because I'll get ready. I'm like all ready to pee. And then a wave comes and it like stops me. Yeah. I don't know. Okay. We don't know.
这也是海浪的原因。因为我准备好了。我感觉都准备好尿尿了。然后一个海浪打过来，它就像把我阻止了。是的。我不知道。好吧。我们不知道。
We don't know. Can you pee in the ocean? New poll. I can. It just takes a lot of effort. Do you remember that thing that they would tell you? Did you hear this when you were a kid? You go to the public swimming pool in your neighborhood or whatever and they would say don't pee in the pool because if
我们不知道。你能在海里尿尿吗？新的民意调查。我可以。只是需要花点力气。你还记得他们以前会告诉你的那件事吗？你小时候听说过这个吗？你去你社区的公共游泳池或什么的，他们会说不要在泳池里尿尿，因为如果
you do it'll turn green. Oh I was a lifeguard at the public pool we would say that. Yeah but that's not true right? It doesn't really change a color. I mean what is that makes no sense. Maybe there's a chemical you can put in the pool. Ours were just like empty threats. So I'll look it up and I'll have an answer by the end of the episode. Oh, we're going to, we're like debunking things or maybe confirming. Okay, so Michael is in the conference room. He's actually doing like a real presentation, like real work. They talked in the commentary that this was like some of the most professional like verbiage you hear Michael say in the whole entire series.
你尿了，水就会变绿。哦，我以前是公共泳池的救生员，我们确实这么说过。对，但那不是真的，对吧？它不会真的变色。我的意思是，那是什么，根本说不通。也许你可以往泳池里加某种化学物质。我们的话只是空洞的威胁。所以我查一下，我会在本集结束前给出一个答案。哦，我们要，我们好像在揭穿真相，或者说是在证实。好了，所以迈克尔在会议室里。他实际上在做一场真正的演讲，做真正的工作。他们在评论中谈到，这是你在整部剧里听到迈克尔说出的最具专业术语的话之一。
But Luke is distracting everyone because he has one of those little laser pointer things. He points it at Oscar's head. He points it to Angela's boob. Michael kicks him out and then he points it into Andy's eyeball. We got a fan question from Elizabeth P in Toronto, Canada, who said, was Luke shining a real laser at people, or was it added later? It was a fakey laser.
但卢克一直在分散大家的注意力，因为他手里拿着那种小激光笔。他把它照在奥斯卡的头上。他把它照在安吉拉的胸部。迈克尔把他赶了出去，然后他把激光照进了安迪的眼球里。我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省多伦多的伊丽莎白·P的粉丝提问，她说：“卢克是在用真正的激光照人，还是后来后期加的？”这是一个假的激光。
Yeah, you can't do that. You could not put a laser in someone's eyeball. That's a CGI laser is my guess. It was, and Randy even sent us like the little video of them adding it in. Michael is gonna run out of the conference room to try to take the laser pointer away from Luke since he's being such a tool with it. And this awkward physical altercation ensues. Michael starts spanking Luke. Spanking him.
对，你不能这么做。你不能把激光射进别人的眼球里。我猜那是CGI激光。确实是的，雷恩甚至给我们发了一小段他们加上激光的视频。迈克尔要跑出会议室，试图把卢克的激光笔抢过来，因为他拿这东西太混蛋了。接着就发生了这场尴尬的肢体冲突。迈克尔开始打卢克的屁股。打他的屁股。
Yeah. On the desk and everyone in the conference room is watching this. Lady, after watching the deleted scenes, when Michael is spanking Luke, all I can think about is his sister Marnie. Yes. How is Michael... She is unfriending him. She will never speak to him again. Yes.
是的。在桌子上，会议室里的每个人都在看着这一幕。女士，看了删减片段后，当迈克尔在打卢克的屁股时，我满脑子想的都是他姐姐玛妮。是的。迈克尔怎么能……她正在取消关注他。她再也不会跟他说一句话了。是的。
Well, Luke is going to run out crying, and Michael comes back into the conference room. We had a fan question from Cessia Z in London, Ontario, Canada. At 18 minutes 40 seconds there's a quick pan of the camera, but if you pause it you can clearly see Jim, Phyllis, and Darryl smiling or maybe breaking. And then as the camera pans you can see Stanley smiling as well. Was this scripted or was everyone actually reacting to the scene and trying not to laugh? All right, I looked at this. Everyone's breaking. I don't know what happened, like what everybody is reacting to, but probably Steve did this like very funny entrance to the conference room and it was
好吧，卢克哭着跑了出去，迈克尔回到了会议室。我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省伦敦市塞西亚·Z的粉丝提问。在18分40秒时，镜头有一个快速的摇晃，但如果你暂停，你可以清楚地看到吉姆、菲利斯和达里尔在笑，或者说可能是在笑场。然后随着镜头摇移，你也可以看到斯坦利在笑。这是剧本安排的，还是每个人其实都在对这个场景做出真实的反应，并试图忍住不笑？好了，我看过这个。每个人都在笑场。我不知道发生了什么，大家到底在对什么做出反应，但可能史蒂夫进会议室时的那个出场方式非常搞笑，这
making people break because you can also see Ed breaking. It's like a group break. The whole scene was just so huge and crazy. We were all just like, I think we were laughing, nervous laughing. We were all just like, oh my god, what's happening? Yes. Well, on the commentary, BJ and Paul talked about the moment they knew this whole
让大家笑场了，因为你也能看到埃德在笑场。这就像是集体笑场。整个场景就是那么宏大和疯狂。我们当时都像是，我想我们都在笑，紧张地笑。我们当时都觉得，天哪，这到底是怎么回事？是的。好吧，在评论中，BJ和保罗谈到了他们知道整段
Luke-Michael storyline was going to have a payoff and work. And in particular, they talked about whose idea it was for Michael to spank Luke. Listen to this. It wasn't until we had this scene that we figured we could... This episode worked. Yeah. In the writing stage, in the outlining stage. Yeah, I was, I was sitting in editing. You came in with a note card. From written by Aaron Schur.
卢克-迈克尔的故事线将会有所回报并奏效的那个时刻。特别是，他们谈到迈克尔打卢克屁股这个主意是谁想出来的。听听这个。直到我们拍了这场戏，我们才觉得我们可以……这集管用了。是的。在剧本创作阶段，在大纲阶段。是的，我当时坐在剪辑室里。你拿着一张便签卡进来了。作者是阿伦·舒尔。
Written by Aaron Schur. They just said Michael Spanx Luke. Yeah. And you said, we got it. Yeah. That's very funny. I texted Aaron and I was like, Aaron, is this true? And he goes, yeah, I'm pretty sure that's right.
作者是阿伦·舒尔。他们只是写了迈克尔打卢克屁股。是的。然后你说，我们搞定了。是的。这太搞笑了。我给阿伦发了信息，我问他：“阿伦，这是真的吗？”他说：“是的，我挺确信是这样的。”
I love it. Well now we're going to go back over to the Elevator Bay. Dwight and Pam are stuck. They've managed to get a technician, a real technician, who was played by Tom Melby. Yes, Tom Melby was our stage manager. He was there the whole entire run of the show. He basically knew everything about the property where we filmed and could fix anything.
我太喜欢了。好吧，现在我们要回到电梯湾。德怀特和帕姆被困住了。他们设法找来了一个技术员，一个真正的技术员，由汤姆·梅尔比饰演。是的，汤姆·梅尔比是我们的舞台经理。他在剧组呆了整整一拍摄季。他基本上了解我们拍摄地点的所有情况，什么都能修好。
And I love that we put him in this episode, working on the elevator. They said in the commentary that Tom was so shy, and that's why he kind of kept his head tucked down. Well, you know, this was a fakie elevator. This was not real. And so this was a fakie elevator. This was not real. And so this was a huge elaborate thing that they had to build of us being stuck between floors, being up high like that with that little opening.
我很高兴我们把他安排在这集里，修理电梯。他们在评论中说汤姆非常害羞，这就是为什么他总是把头低着。好吧，你知道的，这是一个假电梯。这不是真的。所以这是一个假电梯。这不是真的。所以这是一个巨大的、精心制作的东西，他们必须建造它，让我们被困在楼层之间，高高地立在那里，带着那个小小的开口。
Yeah. But all of it, you know, even earlier, you know, we've said the elevator doors opened and closed because there was a crew person like doing a rope on a pulley. So when we had that whole moment before when the elevator's breaking down, that was a very elaborate set of like someone was shaking the elevator, someone was pulling on the pulleys. It was like very like old timey. I was gonna say it sounds like a Bonville show. Yes, that's kind of what it was.
是的。但所有这一切，你知道的，甚至更早的时候，你知道的，我们说过电梯门会打开和关闭，因为有一个剧组人员在滑轮上拉绳子。所以当我们之前有那整段电梯发生故障的时刻时，那是相当精心设计的一套装置，像有人在摇晃电梯，有人在拉滑轮。感觉非常像老式的。我要说这听起来像是一个邦维尔秀。是的，有点那种感觉。
But we actually shot this broken elevator in a completely different spot. It wasn't even in our little lobby. It was over on the warehouse stage on stage four. They recreated the lobby. Michael Gallenberg designed it. Tim James built it. And it was on a platform that was about four feet above the stage. I just remember it was like this really cool thing
但我们实际上是在一个完全不同的地方拍摄这个坏掉的电梯的。它甚至不在我们的小大厅里。它在四号摄影棚的仓库里。他们重建了大厅。迈克尔·盖伦伯格设计的。蒂姆·詹姆斯建造的。它在一个大约高出舞台四英尺的平台上。我只记得这是一个非常酷的东西
that they had to build. And then I had to stand up there. We really were high up. You really were. I have a question for you, Angela. So in this scene where Pam's stuck in the elevator with Dwight, Jim comes over, she's so proud of herself.
他们不得不搭建它。然后我必须站在那里。我们确实站得很高。你们确实很高。我有个问题要问你，安吉拉。所以在帕姆和德怀特被困在电梯里的这场戏里，吉姆过来了，她为自己感到骄傲。
She says, they don't call me the Bart Simpson of Scranton for nothing. Jim says, here, I'll help you down. And she says, nope, it's OK. I'm afraid of getting cut in half. I have a question. OK. If you were stuck like Pam, would you
她说：“他们不叫我斯克兰顿的巴特·辛普森才怪呢。”吉姆说：“来吧，我拉你下来。”她说：“不，没关系。我害怕被切成两半。”我有个问题。好吧。如果你像帕姆那样被困住，你会
go through the little opening, or would you be afraid of being cut in half? I mean, I don't want to be cut in half. But I think in that moment, I would just want out. So I think I would go for it. If I could just slip right out there, I'd probably go for it. I don't think I would do it because I would just think of that scene and speed. Yes!
穿过那个小小的开口，还是会害怕被切成两半？我的意思是，我可不想被切成两半。但我觉得在那种情况下，我只想出去。所以我认为我会去尝试。如果我能从那里直接溜出去，我可能会去试一试。我觉得我不会这么做，因为我会想起《死神来了》里的那个场景。是的！
When they're stuck in the elevator and they're having the people come through. Yeah. And it keeps falling. You can't hesitate. It keeps falling. Is that it? You can't hesitate. I mean, they had to have me say that because they wanted the visual comic gag of like me being in this broken elevator.
当他们被困在电梯里，让人们穿过来的时候。是的。而且它一直在下坠。你不能犹豫。它一直在下坠。是这样吗？你不能犹豫。我的意思是，他们必须让我这么说，因为他们想要那种视觉喜剧效果，比如我被困在这个坏掉的电梯里。
Why is Pam not coming out? I probably would have already crawled out if those guys would have let me. That's very funny. Well wrapping up this episode, Michael has earned the respect of his coworkers. Luke was a real problem and he got rid of Luke and they're happy about it. They have a whole scene where they're pretending to spank each other. However, Gabe is not happy that Michael assaulted an employee at work. And to deal with it, he tells Michael he's going to need to attend six counseling sessions. And Michael's like,
为什么帕姆不出来？如果那些人肯放我走的话，我可能已经爬出去了。这太搞笑了。好吧，总结这一集，迈克尔赢得了同事们的尊重。卢克是个真正的麻烦，他摆脱了卢克，他们对此很高兴。他们有一整场戏，都在假装打对方的屁股。然而，加布对迈克尔在工作场所袭员工感到很不高兴。为了处理这件事，他告诉迈克尔他需要参加六次心理咨询。而迈克尔的反应是：
that's it? No problem. Except your counselor will be Toby. What? It's literally be fired or do six counseling sessions with Toby and Michael isn't sure what he wants. He really takes a long lingering look. And on the commentary, they said that was Steve, that choice to make that look of like, hmm, well, should I just call it quits? This is going to lead into next week's episode, which is that counseling session between Michael and Toby. It is delicious. Before we go, Angela, we got this letter from Catherine P. in Bellevue, Nebraska, and it really touched my heart, so I wanted to share. Okay.
就这样？没问题。不过你的心理咨询师将是托比。什么？这简直就是要么被开除，要么和托比进行六次心理咨询，迈克尔不确定自己想要什么。他真的给了一个长久而依依不舍的眼神。在评论中，他们说那是史蒂夫的主意，做出那个眼神的选择，就像是“嗯，好吧，我是不是该破罐子破摔了？”这将会引出下周的剧集，也就是迈克尔和托比之间的那场心理咨询。太精彩了。在我们离开之前，安吉拉，我们收到了来自内布拉斯加州贝尔维尤的凯瑟琳·P的这封信，它真的触动了我的心，所以我想要分享一下。好吧。
Catherine said, I wanted to tell you that this episode is incredibly meaningful to my family. I started watching The Office on Netflix when I was pregnant with my oldest and just found out she would need heart surgery after she was born. It was not only a lifesaver, but fast forward to my daughter born and waiting for surgery, on her bad days we would watch this episode specifically. My husband and entire family know
凯瑟琳说：“我想告诉你们，这一集对我的家庭有着极其重要的意义。当我怀着大女儿时，我在Netflix上开始看《办公室》，刚发现她出生后需要做心脏手术。这不仅是救命稻草，而且快进到我的女儿出生并等待手术的日子里，在她状态不好的日子里，我们会专门看这一集。我的丈夫和整个家庭都知道
that season seven, episode one is the lip dub. My daughter would smile and light up for her favorite faces singing just for her. She had surgery at four months old right before Christmas. The office kept us going during a very hard time for our little warrior. I took pictures of her laying in her swing, pleased as punch to be watching the lip dub for what had to have been the thousandth time. She is now a thriving and perfectly healthy eight-year-old and we are forever
第七季第一集就是对口型视频。每当那些专门为她唱歌的最喜欢的面孔出现时，我的女儿就会微笑并双眼放光。她在四个月大、圣诞节前夕做了一次手术。在我们这个小勇士经历非常艰难的时期，《办公室》支撑着我们。我拍下了她躺在秋千上的照片，看对口型视频看了大概有一千遍，高兴得不得了。她现在是一个茁壮成长且完全健康的八岁儿童，我们永远
grateful to the Scranton branch. P.S. she had an opportunity to meet Kate Flannery several years ago and she hasn't stopped talking about it since. That just made me tear up. I know. Catherine, can we please send your daughter some office lady stuff? We would love to send her something. Thank you so much for sharing that. I'm so glad that our show could be there for you and your family. Yeah, I love it that this episode specifically has a special place in your heart.
对斯克兰顿分公司充满感激。”P.S. 几年前她有机会见到凯特·弗兰内利，她从那以后就一直在谈论这件事。这直接让我眼泪掉下来。我知道。凯瑟琳，我们能给你的女儿寄一些《办公室女士》的周边吗？我们很乐意给她寄点东西。非常感谢你分享这个。我很高兴我们的节目能在你和你的家人需要的时候陪伴你们。是的，我特别喜欢这一集在你的心中有着特殊的位置。
Catherine, we're going to email you. Be on the lookout for it. Well, you guys, that was nepotism. Sam was waving at us. Sam, what do you got? Did you find out about peeing in the pool? I did. If you look up at the TV, I believe you'll find your answer.
凯瑟琳，我们会给你发邮件。请留意查收。好吧，伙计们，那是裙带关系。萨姆在向我们挥手。萨姆，你有什么发现？你查到关于在泳池里尿尿的事了吗？查到了。如果你抬头看电视，我相信你会找到你的答案。
Oh, all right. Here it is. Does a swimming pool urine detecting dye actually exist? It says no such chemical is used. Doesn't exist. But 52% of people believe there is a chemical that when added to a pool will turn your urine a color. You guys.
好吧，给你。泳池尿液检测染料真的存在吗？上面说没有这种化学物质。不存在。但52%的人认为有一种化学物质，加到泳池里会把你的尿液变成某种颜色。天哪。
We basically all believed our moms are people at the public pool. It goes on to say, regardless, pools are not meant to be peed in because urine contains bacteria that you would not want to swim in. Please do not pee in pools. There you have it, guys. Yeah. It won't turn a color, but you shouldn't do it anyway. Well that was nepotism. Yeah, thank you for listening. We love you guys. Thank you to
我们基本上都相信了妈妈们或公共泳池里的人的话。接着上面说，无论如何，泳池不是用来小便的，因为尿液中含有细菌，你不会想在里面游泳的。请不要在泳池里小便。好了，就是这样，各位。是的。它不会变色，但你无论如何都不应该这样做。好吧，那是裙带关系。是的，谢谢你们的收听。我们爱你们。感谢
Randy Cordray, Matt Sohn, Dave Rogers, Kate Flannery, Creed Bratton, and Erin Schur for letting us reach out to you about this episode. And thank you for sending in your questions and comments. Next week we are going to have a rerun of Beach Games and then the following week we will have an all-new episode, Counseling. See you then! Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jer Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is
Randy Cordray、Matt Sohn、Dave Rogers、Kate Flannery、Creed Bratton和Erin Schur让我们就这一集联系你们。也谢谢你们发来问题和评论。下周我们将重播《海滩运动》（Beach Games），接下来的那周我们将有一集全新节目《心理咨询》（Counseling）。到时见！再见！感谢收听《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）。《办公室女士》由Earwulf、Jenna Fischer和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的节目执行制片人是Cody Fisher。我们的制片人是Cassie Jer Cody Fisher，我们的制片人是Cassie Jerkins，我们的音响工程师是Sam Kiefer，我们的副制片人是
Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies go to Stitcher Premium dot com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium Use Code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Ainsley Bubico。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton创作的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版的《Office Ladies》，请访问Stitcher Premium dot com。注册Stitcher Premium可享一个月免费试用，优惠码为Office。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。